e
e e
three I'll call the meeting together of
finance division 2 and welcome in our
friends from the Department of
Transportation and please uh that right
here Department of Transportation
right I got to look
like it's not over
yet um please introduce yourselves and
then and and begin thank you sure uh
thank you for having us I'm Bill Cass
the commissioner from New Hampshire dot
with me is Danielle Shandra she's our
director of uh Finance uh there are
several other folks that if they get
called on to help answer the questions
we can um we can bring up and and
introduce at the time so but I have uh
several staff here that so we should be
able to walk you through the budget and
ask and answer any questions that that
that you might have so so I guess in
terms of process it looks have a nice
slide deck which we can open open up
with I assume that's your plan but we
would like to go through the actual
budget Page by Page yes okay right I
would be I mean I I'll be very brief
from the presentation just it's very
high level hopefully it I yeah we we
tried to organize it to make it a a
higher level summary but uh I'd just
like to step through that very quickly
and if that's fine and then we have
plenty of time I think hopefully we'll
all survive the time and I know I know
at our an introductory um uh meeting an
overview the were a number of questions
I know we provided through Mickey uh a a
lot of information to answer those
questions and if there are any questions
on any of that material we can answer
those questions as well too and along
those lines do you mind being
interrupted while you're presenting or
not at all no okay so feel free to let
me know that you you have any questions
while he's going for okay yours and I'll
try to be clear and and uh you know
sometimes I know I do laps maybe into
acronyms or things like that so please
if something we say isn't clear
definitely uh uh ask I'll try to be
clear so I can start with our uh step
through the presentation I also wanted
to point out um traditionally we have
provided a uh a a budget book which um
you know kind of summarizes in pictures
our our budget and the organizational
structure and and a little more detail
on each of the um Aus each of the
organizational units um some pictures
and the accomplishments of what they use
this forms the basis of our annual
report but we found it a a helpful
internal reference and if you want a
little bit more information about what
bridge maintenance or project
development or any one of the orgs that
uh it's a little less sterile than the
than the than the budget summary so
that's uh hopefully that that helps but
we won't go through that that is there
as a as a as a reference if you find it
helpful Does it include count numbers so
I can tie it to the it does yes yep it's
organized in the same uh the same stru
structure by the uh uh Aus and the
organal organizational units yes great
thank
you so um I will step through our uh
budget presentation very very quickly
the first page was our mission and and
purpose the second page was our
organizational structure just a
refresher um uh that uh we're uh about
a650 uh Personnel organization divided
into uh five Ma divisions each division
overseen by a director and the summary
of The divisions and and the uh uh
bureaus underneath those divisions are
on that organizational chart um the next
Slide the next two slides just give a
very top level funding summary of our of
our overall budget and the type of
funding that that goes in there so our
FY
2026 Governor's recommended budget total
for the agency is 79 $95.99 million it's
virtually the same as our FY 25 adjusted
authorized um and the percentage
breakdown of of the of the funding is is
is shown there primarily funded by uh
Turnpike funds Highway funds um other
funds bulk of our funding is is
federally funded in our construction
programs and things like that and that
little blue that little green insert is
the very thin slice of of uh General
funds that support our um
non-highway uh organizational
units um on the next page the pie charts
there just kind of show a little bit of
how we tend to break up our our our
budget into two major components uh
Municipal Aid and construction on on the
left it's about 54 55% of our budget um
a lot of that is our construction
program and just as a refresher a lot of
the decisions about those Investments
and and how uh the program is developed
is uh taken up in the off budget year
when we developed the state's 10-year um
um transportation Improvement program um
the operating budget which is the uh
Browner half of of that pie chart really
represents our operational budget uh
which is
primarily uh I think the focus of of of
division 2 in this uh this budget
process um and that's about 46% of our
overall budget all the funding and and
stuff here is shown there but but like I
said most of the discretionary most of
the budgetary stuff that we talk about
with our operating budget is contained
in that half of the pie and some of the
percentages um we didn't break them down
but the majority of of the municipal Aid
and
construction uh funding that comes from
the federal federal program our Federal
Highway program FTA for the transit FAA
for the Aeronautics you know all of
those programs that flow through on the
operating side the the the primary
funding source for our operational needs
is the state highway fund so uh very
just brief reminder there perh on Murray
thank you sorry to stop so early but I
was just um Turnpike funds are for
turnpikes correct okay so I was just
confused when it's you have it under
unrestricted funds but technically isn't
a a restricted fund because it is only
can be used in turnpikes as opposed to
you know moving it over to something
else and isn't that also the case with
the highway funds restricted for use but
they're still considered unrestricted
from the state perspective okay thank
you
yeah it's an Enterprise fund but it's
not a restricted fund is that a good way
to say it I mean it's self-funded within
the turnpike system it can only be used
for the turnpike system and and that's
tied to the RSA um the highway tied to
uh the
Constitution but from a Statewide
Financial perspective they they're
looked at as unrestricted funds
okay um if you turn the page um we don't
have page numbers I apologize but uh
that just gives a a a sense of our
positions and the trends um we have been
very level in terms of number of full
budgeted full-time positions since uh
2014 we've maintained uh uh that uh
level of Staffing but uh the red line
there represents vehicle miles traveled
or or use of the transportation system
um and and that has increased so um the
bottom part of that chart also shows you
know some of the recent Trends uh that
we've been dealing with a ever
increasing uh vacancy rate um and I I
like to point out that this this in my
mind demonstrates that I think do is an
efficient a agency we uh continue to
perform and continue to do more with
less
so the the next um how are those the
vacant positions are they funded or
unfunded they are funded okay thank you
in an Ideal World they would we would we
would we would fill those positions you
know we believe that's a staffing level
we we need to um deliver the services uh
to the level of uh to the levels that
people would expect um again I think
further on in the budget I I talk about
we're getting done what we what we have
to have to get done as we continually
prioritize um but maybe not all that we
should be doing or would like to be
doing
so
um the next the next slide uh just kind
of summarizes um some of the Aus in
there but it really highlights the uh
the budget targets that we were given to
meet our general fund budget Target was
$1.88 million Turnpike fund was
$458 Million which represents about a
you know a flat um a flat Revenue
Outlook in the highway fund was about
$250 million again a flat level
projection to meet these um to meet
these budget targets the you know one of
the things we had done and I've got a
very brief summary of where they
happened we unfunded seven permanent
positions and nine temporary full-time
positions uh as part of the effort to
meet these uh budget targets uh and
there are a few areas that we can
highlight as we get into the budget
where we feel we're purposely
underfunding uh some efforts uh and we
did that in order to meet the budget
targets is that noted on here on the
slide it's it's uh uh I it's it's it's
not it's not highlighted there uh it's
summarized in the next several slid so
I'm just rolling up from the next
several slides but it ALS there I'll a
place where notes that they're actually
s unfunded positions yes okay thank you
so if you turn the page um where we talk
about Aeronautics Rail and Transit um
very that very top box of of um how we
met those budget targets so that's the
that's the one area that is um generally
funded in the department um so uh in
order to meet that uh budget Target of
about it was on the previous page our
general fund budget Target was about
$1.8
million um previous budgets had funded
uh State Transit operating match at
around $1.8 million per year uh of
General funds that was a special um
general fund appropriation for that
match in the last budget um in order to
meet the budget targets we weren't able
to fund that this year uh in this budget
and um
about $200,000 of
reallocated uh
um budget authority to pay for
drone handles uh drones what does uas
stand for unmanned unmanned aerial
system I apologize um uh and uh shifted
that position from Bureau of Aeronautics
to be funded with Highway funds so a
couple questions here sure can you just
for me being new to this what is the
state Transit operating match yes so um
we provide the the the through through
the department we provide FTA funds for
uh FTA is Federal Transit Authority for
local um and Community Transit uh
operations
um typically those federal funds require
a a match um most of the operating most
of the operating um federal funds
require about a 50% match historically
um the state has provided very little
assistance to the local Transit agencies
in in coming up with and and meeting
that match in the last budget cycle with
increasing um federal funds there was a
um willingness from the from the
legislature to provide some uh
additional support for local um Transit
operators in um Meeting those match
requirements to the tune of about $1.8
million a
year so by reducing that you also lost
some federal funds that you would have
matched with it or that remains to be
seen there is it the there is there is
the potential there is I guess the
potential that uh some Federal Transit
funds may not be able to be utilized for
for lack of match um that uh again that
remains to be seen uh whether whether
local communities uh whether the local
Transit agencies can can find find or
come up with that match um the one
interesting thing with Federal it funds
is the utilization of those funds extend
over a number of a number of years so
the implications of of
um of potential loss of FTA funds may
not be realized for for several years
down the
road and regarding the alternately
altern the way refunded the uas position
with the highway fund so as opposed to
what how had it been funded it had been
previously funded as part of the
operating uh uh costs for the Bureau of
Aeronautics with General funds a big
part of that position we feel good job
it it well thank you it's a uh a bit one
of the reasons that allows us to do that
is those positions support uh a lot of
the project development activities some
of the survey some of the uh supporting
um mapping and so forth for um Federal
federally funded projects um so it'll so
that it was
a there was a Nexus there was a
reasonable uh accommodation to make is
that a fa way to State it it is and uh
it will be restricted by the
Constitution so so that us uas Position
will need to only work on Highway
related work it will not be able to work
on other it can't work on Turnpike work
and it cannot work on any general funded
uh work as well so at a high level could
you explain to me how
Highway fund is sort of as I understand
it comes in through safety and they gets
split into I guess mostly transportation
and safety MH do they control it do you
control it how does that work you
control it the legis I
totally maybe I should rephrase my
question how have we set it up to be
controlled so for instance if I was
going to do things that would increase
the revenue flowing into the highway
fund how would I direct that to you if I
wanted to to your to the transportation
if I want
H hb2 or something
[Music]
you there are some statutory you know
guidelines as far as uh limiting the uh
appropriation to uh safety or or other
things and but I know in the past the
legislature has has waved some of those
um restrictions Mr but I would say okay
Mr land again just to remind everyone
how it works so unrestricted Highway
funds which mainly the road toll lot of
Motor Vehicle fees goes into the Highway
F we have the Surplus statement that we
walk uh the committee through all of
those Appropriations are made by Finance
by the house bill House Bill one
sometimes House Bill two so there is no
mechanism for Department to access those
on their own so to speak so safety
doesn't pull or whatever it's all
appropriated in the budget uh both
departments do have a mechanism to draw
from Surplus with fiscal committee and
GNC approval but all the Appropriations
are made through the operating budget
process so clearly must have some idea
of what that appropriation is because
they've made this switch from General
funds to Highway funds knowing that they
had the highway funds available to do
this
position and that is the Surplus
statement as a balancing document to
know what is available for Highway fund
so when the governor's office put
together its budget uh it would have
looked at and I'm speaking at attorney
or somewh they would have looked at that
there's available Highway funds to fund
this or maybe there weren't General
funds to do so
okay and this that that that switch of
the position here was our own internal
balancing of the Department's budget and
the Department's funding streams
so represent of wer chairman wer what's
the main use of the unmanned aerial
system system how many hours a year
would you say it gets used how many
different drones are there we have two
full-time positions that that support it
um I can have Andre our Deputy
Commissioner give you more more details
but primarily uh it's it's used to
support uh Department activities uh
mapping surveillance not surveillance
but but survey I should say survey
mapping um a lot of it is support of
um survey I mean when we have uh you
know projects there's there's uh uh you
know a lot of mapping and things that
that that go on to develop the plans and
stuff um and uh utilizing the um the
drones and and stuff support support
that it also is utilized um when we had
uh storms last summer for emergency um
assessment of damage and stuff there
were areas um in the North Country uh
last July June July when there were big
storms um along some of the railroad
corridors where we couldn't get access
and using the uh the drones helped us
assemble that information provide um
estimates to FEMA for reimbursement and
things like that the first time hearing
of it how long have you been using these
uh so we're about at the a little over
the fiveyear point uh and Andre Brier
Deputy Commissioner thank you and uh I
do remember uh representative wer um
talking to you this was probably coming
on two years ago maybe a year and a half
ago talking to you about uh how we were
utilizing a uh a deployment study that
that was funded by the legislature gave
us an opportunity to kind of rethink and
organize the uas um Enterprise moving
forward and um we did so I'm I'm happy
to report that we are able to hold the
first
Statewide uh uas community of Interest
meeting um we convened that over at dot
last month so all agencies and state
government that operate uas uh are
coming together now once a quarter to
talk about best acquisition practices
efficiencies if we can um achieve
economies of scale by doing Mass
purchases um and really coordinating how
we use it there's two broad Mission sets
um one being law enforcement the other
being what we do which is really survey
and um aiding construction aiding uh
natural disaster recovery so we are
really progressing as a state when it
comes to efficiently using these
platforms we've got all kinds of neat
things that are going to enable us to
more real time monitor the quality of
construction that's happening on our
roads um we have some great uh some
great video that I'd be happy to show
any member that shows really some
amazing things that we can get value to
the state using these we can see real
time when a uh when a Paving um contract
is happening and they're doing an
incorrect seam where in the past we it
may have taken a year to discover poor
construction now we can see it real time
using infrared we can estimate amounts
quantities of construction material so
we know that we're not getting chiseled
you know real time so it's that type of
thing but it's incredibly useful you
just have do you have one or two or we
have we have uh I think it's around five
now yeah and and uh ranging from large
to small the real Innovation moving
forward is purchasing more uh small uas
that can be uh deployed by construction
teams in the field size are these 20 ft
long 10 ft long um they range from you
know dinner plate uh all the way to
something you know that's wingspan is
about the size of this table when you're
talking uh heavier platforms liar um
where we can see through trees
and things like that so a lot cheaper
than an airplane a lot cheaper a lot
cheaper to run and a lot more efficient
and there's really uh Innovative and
interesting laws that are going to come
on the books from the feds in the coming
years which are going to allow things
like Beyond line of sight use where you
could launch it from do headquarters go
20 miles away do do a do a mission and
come back without the operator having to
go you can sit there in the headquarters
real time and say okay look what's
happening rather than wait for somebody
to give you a report much more efficient
uh that way Del yes sir we once had a
chairman of this committee that was
anti drones because he thought they were
just going to go around peeking in
people's windows right which and we got
we have to guard against that but like
I've said in various Forum uh for we
don't look at people we look at roads so
that's what we do with the Department of
Transportation thank you yes
sir uh rep have can Phil up hack can
Phil thank you uh thank you so much just
as a follow-up question I want to make
sure that I'm understanding correctly
that there are two U positions and one
is that you're um funding that Source
differently with Highway funds
exclusively so that the other position
is still a general funded position and
that they can carry on that scope of
scope of work I assume that you're still
covering both your bases but you're just
um reallocating funding and their scope
of I guess work that's correct that's
correct yep and as a follow-up question
Mr chair
um what is the impact of um the split
what are you unable or no longer able to
do with the second position if or is
everything still covered and should be
copacetic I would say everything is
covered and copacetic it said it creates
a little bit more administrative uh uh
uh burden because of uh the fact that
that it is uh you know to fund that
position it has to be restricted to only
working on federal aid eligible uh
projects and activities but um when we
looked at the uh the workload and the
amount of uh you know support that that
position that those activities provide
it was a it was a reasonable um it was a
reasonable um switch to make and it is
important to note that those uh the way
we're structured we knew we couldn't add
any more positions so those aren't are
only uh drone operators we're also our
plan moving forward and we're currently
implementing it is to cross Trin
existing dot employees to operate drones
as well get them their licenses that way
we can draw on a a larger expert pool
without adding positions moving forward
that's been our strategy and there's
more than enough Highway work we're NE
none of these people none of these
positions no matter how they're funded
are ever uh short of work so we have a
very long uh cue for um for drone work
moving ahead and this seems to
work you want to proceed so um the next
if we if we if they flip the page over
uh we just kind of summarize uh uh the
policy and
administration um uh division uh
again Finance did I Mis Finance I'm
sorry oh Finance is at the bottom so
don't flip the page over right below
Aeronautics Rail and Transit is the
division of of of Finance thank you
because there were some changes there we
needed to make so in order to meet
budget targets and and
um uh address the budget there we
reduced uh we eliminated two full-time
positions there um there was some
reduction in the print shop equipment
purchases um and we had some deeper Cuts
in FY 27 overtime temporary help in
equipment and supplies in order to meet
the budget
targets um so when you had asked uh
represent the ver about the you know so
I've summarized the my my initial
statement I kind of rolled those all up
Department wide but these are where the
um you know position eliminations were
were made to uh to meet budget targets
you hav know what account that
is this particular account 301 31 yes
and when we get to going through the the
um the org by org we we can highlight
those as well too yeah thank you and um
now turning the page to policy and
administration uh again that was an an
area where to meet budget targets we
eliminated a temporary full-time
position reduced budget budgeted
overtime and temporary help to meet
budget targets um there are some
implications with with that as uh as as
we move forward that we'll have to
manage on the uh the bottom of that uh
on on the next page there talking about
the the vision of project development
which includes um also the municipal Aid
and our federal aid program uh to meet
budget targets there um we reduced uh
had a reduction of 12 positions and and
I should point out um in the bottom
right corner of each one of these is the
is the total number of of uh permanent
positions in that division so you get a
sense of you know how many you know
where the reductions are and what the
impacts are so in uh project development
we had a reduction of 12 positions three
permanent full-time positions nine
temporary full-time positions um out of
uh that division has about 374 total
permanent positions so so going
backwards you actually added positions
in the previous no we're actually
reclassing uh positions they were in a
in the wrong division so in the in the
turnpike division you'll see a change
when we go through that could you just
tie the two together so I can make note
of that y
um the other the other change in the
budget you see some numbers when we go
go through it we we did realign the
safety section um to make them uh to
elevate that safety section and make it
a direct report to the commissioner's
office in ter in terms of um so there
were eight positions that were within
that safety section that that had moved
out from project development under under
um under the commissioner's office so
you'll see that that that change but
it's just a swap from one One Division
to another
um um the next page after that we do had
I think we had covered this the last
time was just some of those um facts and
figures about the uh about the highway
fund uh and uh how particularly in the
middle of that you know we had some
questions earlier about the split of of
how Highway fund Revenue has been
appropriated so in FY 24 I think % ver
to your question 57% of the uh Highway
fund Revenue was appropriated to dot
about 30% to other agencies primarily
the department of safety but there are
some other agencies that get one or 2%
and about 133% of the highway fund
Revenue appropriated to
municipalities and who is it that I mean
I know it's us that controls this but
who is it that collects for instance
registration fees and that sort of thing
that's the department of safety
department of safety yeah they can they
the DMV collects the registration fees
and the um the road toll Bureau collects
the gas tax so they'd be the one best
suited to make recommendations and that
kind of thing and how how like how long
ago they were raised and so on so forth
yes yes thank you certainly the
interesting thing is that the uh court
has been a dollar amount forever $2
million a year I'm surprised they
haven't come and said oh we need to
inflate that with inflation huh yeah
it's the same 2 million for as long as
we remember right yeah yeah yeah 30
years or so yeah I don't know if it's
been scrutinized or looked at closely
recently but and the Lilac
fund we have that in in we have that in
the in the details so um but but again
the bottom of that talks about the
revenue is flat and incrementally
declining in in the long term um the
there have been a number of one-time
fixes to the highway fund general fund
infusions over the years years in order
to uh address shortages and and balance
the highway
fund um the next page just summarizes
the uh the division of operations which
is by far and uh by by large our our
largest uh
division uh total personnel there of
about
1150 um full-time permanent positions to
uh meet budget targets there uh this is
where we had uh eliminated or or
unfunded three permanent full-time
positions two temporary full-time
positions and we also I again I had
alluded to that we were underfunding
purposely underfunding some areas in
order to meet budget targets
historically we have uh underfunded uh
winter maintenance uh we tend to try to
m m we tend to try to budget for a
three-year average um every every year
can be higher or or lower um through
discussions with with with the with the
legislature it has been um viewed as as
as you know purposefully underfunding or
or funding very optimistically and and
if if it is a uh more um severe winter
to go back to uh fiscal committee um
with the exact numbers so that has been
that's what we've done a couple of times
this year to date but and how's it
looking this year in terms of the rest
of the year as far as we have uh fiscal
will be seeing next month another
another uh transfer to support um the
activities that have uh happened through
February and through the end of the year
so to date we've transferred uh in in
this fy2 425 budget about well FY 25
budget it's a close to $10 million that
that we've had to uh transfer into
winter maintenance to cover winter costs
and if you include if you include the uh
retention incentive they would bring it
up to about 12 and a half 13 what is it
that you're including there the
retention incentive for staff the $5,000
in to keep people in their seats
y so we can get into more detail when we
get to the budget there but th those are
the um the the real the real highlights
um the next the next page just
summarizes the the turnpike Fund in the
turnpike system I think representative
Murray you had had asked about the
turnpike fund again that is
um 89 miles of of freeway that are uh
solely supported by the by the um by the
tolls not the road toll but the actual
toll plazas on on those on those
facilities and um um you know that fund
is um again not restricted funds but the
but the funding on the turnike system is
is is is is restricted to just take care
of the turnpike system um and the
revenue projections are are there um the
very last page is uh before we get into
the the detailed uh sheet by sheet uh
budget review um just some I just wanted
to highlight uh some of the additional
needs and uh we we hit on them but um
the top of that page uh you know really
kind of summarizes what we had
identified for ident additional needs
that weren't funded in the governor's
budget we've prioritized them there um
Danielle had just mentioned the
retention incentive program for the last
three years um in order to uh combat
vacancies and to meet um you know winter
maintenance um needs we've had a uh uh
about a 2.83 $3 million what's that
three and A5 million um uh winter um
incentive bonus retention incentive
bonus um and that has has
um you know brought you know volunteers
to uh people that work for the dot and
other areas that have uh CDL licenses
that can plow um by offering that that
um that that incentive bonus they
volunteer to to plow and uh it it makes
up this year it made up about half of
the vacancies and allowed us to be
successful through through the through
through the winter so um
again from one of our priority needs we
don't see
that uh vacancy issue being meaningfully
changed in the foreseeable future and in
order to continue to keep up with winter
maintenance needs we see the need to
continue this this this program um and
that would be our highest uh additional
need to look to fund or include in the
budget more so than deferred maintenance
more so than deferred maintenance yeah
yeah
they're both they're both High needs but
we can't do what we do without without
people um to uh man those trucks
so um the equipment replacement program
um again to maintain Fleet efficiency
that's an area that uh you know based on
all of our
statistics and the age of the fleet and
so forth we should be investing about $1
million a year to
um you know to keep up with with the
with the with the fleet um keep it in
good working order um last budget um at
the end of the budget in hb2 there was a
$4.8 million additional um need to uh to
meet those um equipment replacement
needs that was funded with the general
fund at the end of it so it wasn't
reflected in our base budget um and as
we uh again tried to meet budget targets
that was an area that again is
underfunded from the foreseeable need
that that that we have um and the was it
funded at the 11 million or is this
funded something lower than that the
currently in your current budget
currently it's budgeted about half of
about half of that half of the 11
million yes right thank
you and then I I had uh mentioned we had
talked recently we had just talked about
winter maintenance as well too where
we're purposefully underfunding that
from what we would typically budget for
three a average
so um and lastly if if we have time if
we get to it I there are a couple of
things um for uh for hb2 that we that
that we'd like to talk to the um
committee about as well too um we need
to budget some additional restricted
Transit revenues this deals with a
recently um a a a recently executed
contract with a a public private
partnership
um that um that we have a long-term
lease for someone to operate the uh
Portsmouth and Dover Transit centers and
uh per the contract some of the revenue
that comes in for that needs to be
restricted for that use um we didn't
necessarily realize that or set that up
when we were uh developing the budget
back uh last at the end of last summer
um and so there's Revenue to address
with that as well as the restricted
accounts to facilitate that
so so that's a very high level o
overview it took me longer than I think
I told you five minutes but we got more
question you're fine that was very good
so
yeah and then I you know however you
want to proceed if you want us to to
just hit Page by Page or if you want to
yeah go Page by Page and when you come
to things that are just mostly federally
funded you can maybe just point that out
and probably move past those more
rapidly I would imagine
okay you want to lead or you want me to
represent Murr yeah thank you because we
usually don't look you know a lot of the
the federal funds that's outside our
purview but in uh I think there are
instances can you point out if there's
um concern about losing some federal
funds and if that loss of the funds will
impact uh what we have to do or will
impact your ability to do your job so if
there's you know that kind of a concern
that spills
out of the federal into some State
concerns so thank
you I start I guess sure all right so
the first so so the budget starts on
page
774 for you and it starts with the
division of Aeronautics Rail and Transit
funds the accounting unit is 2021 it's
Federal local projects it's used for
infrastructure projects funded by um the
airport and this is 100% uh Federal
funded
and one of the little odd balls about
about this is the the majority of the
federal funds for Aeronautics for for uh
for airports the uh FAA funds um have
historically gone through the capital
budget so uh
hb25 um will be another area to discuss
um um Aeronautics funding at least for
the FAA programs and the airport um
Improvement programs
yes um two 29 um Airway toll
fund um this is for um airport
infrastructure and maintenance projects
funded by um an aviation fuel fee that's
collected by the department of
safety um it complies with FAA uh
requirements requiring a DED a dedicated
fund um in FY 23 25 airports are
eligible to receive these funds which
provides support for planning rehab
development equipment safety security
and
mitigation
um and the majority all of this is
agency
income it is
the uh Airway toll fund it's also called
it's the airway toll fund um and it
collects the aviation fuel
fee uh 2050 is the state bus service and
facilities and the majority of this is
um federal funds there's a a little bit
of money associated with Surplus sales
that would be the agency income there
and some miscellaneous reimbursements
from insurance but the majority of this
is federal
funds right and the majority of this
Murray
no I the majority of this the state
services and Facilities deals with the
Boston express service that that the
department runs and the um the park and
ride facilities or or the bus terminal
facilities um that that the department
owns and
maintains this isn't the the SE coast
and the nashille and the other one
that's I have a question about that when
we get to that part of it sure right no
but that's why it's separated out
because this is par particularly the
state um the state bus services and
Facilities represent
could you explain I'm newbie can you
explain to me your your private
partnership uh public private
partnership with those two organizations
that um I assume you're talking about
the one that's in Dober and then there's
the Boston Express yes well um Boston
Express is a service that that that the
state runs we have a uh um a contract
with a with an entity that operates the
service on behalf of of the state but
it's a state it's a state-run service
um on the facilities over in the Sea
Coast on Portsmouth Park and Ride
facility and the Dover Park and Ride
facility we had just recently um uh done
a P3 public private partnership um uh
RFP to solicit a um a a a vendor to um
on a longterm 35-year lease to uh run
and operate those facilities uh for us
and take us take the Department of
Transportation take the state out of the
day-to-day uh maintenance and operation
of of those
facilities and that that was um um C&J
CJ it was the successful um proponent of
that and they are currently um operating
those facilities they recently is part
of their business model had you probably
seen if you're from over there the um
the um uh small fee for parking and the
use of those facilities
and that oh I'm sorry go ahead go ahead
that the the net result of that P3 and
the problems we were really going after
there were number one the the abuse of
those parking facilities especially
during peak times where there would be
you know no parking available for
families that were trying to take
vacation during school breaks um because
so many local residents were using it
using it as an extension of their
driveway and parking wreck vehicles and
things like that um so this very small
reasonable fee has turned these
facilities into net um costs to the
department in the state to revenue
generators for the for this for the
state so we get a a reasonable uh base
rent for those facilities from uh the
vendor uh in addition to six points on
Gross parking Revenue it's actually all
uh gross um Revenue uh if so if they
decide to add a service or or a lunch
count or something like that we would
get six points off that gross as well um
so uh it's going to add uh actually um
Jim jalbert uh who runs that company is
already uh has improvements on the books
for the facilities themselves uh greater
security improved lighting uh and during
this last school break uh had good
parking availability for all the
families that wanted to use that for um
leaving the state for vacation can I ask
follow just follow up so when that first
started out you we own the land the
state owned the land that these
facilities were bought brought into it's
correct it's it's a uh it's a little
more complicated just because um part of
the parking land at Portsmith is is uh
owned by PDA okay um but so it's a
that's a shared facility so the contract
for Portsmith itself is is a three-party
contract between PDA uh and hdot
representing the state and the vendor uh
do is is 100% uh run by do by do
wonderful thank you for sharing that I
appreciate it Y no thank you for your
interest on to
Aeronautics uh 2107 is Aeronautics that
is the accounting unit that does the
administration of the Aeronautics
program the majority of that is funded
with
um General funds so this is the largest
um general fund uh ask in here is the
aeronomics program it does have some um
transfers so when we talked about the
transfer of the uas position you can see
the cost of that here so o4 intra agency
transfers is the cost of that uh
position and associated costs and then
the agency income 09 is the aircraft
registration income that we get for that
but the majority of this accounting unit
is General funded what was that first uh
number you gave me class number for the
people the class number
21 no no I got the account number yes
it's under the estimated sources of
funds for Aeronautics class number 004
so 004 is is where the position where
you're seeing the revenue come in from
the highway side that's the inter agency
transfers and okay so that was Zero
before where did it come from it comes
from the highway side it's the highway
fund the highway is funding that
position so shows up as agency income
because it's an inter agency transfer
we'll see another I get that I'm trying
to understand in FY 2425 where would I
see the numbers
it's not there in well it's obviously
not there in this account but you're
saying it was somewhere
else
no it's in the general f in the general
fund it was in that yeah the general
fund it's just part of that 1.4 to 1.3
million correct at the B correct okay
thank
you up suar thank you very much um can
you just some maybe I was trying to type
and think at the same time where did why
did the federal money go away can you
just just give a narrative around what
happened to the federal money and how
this ended up you know with a big chunk
of General
funds what federal money go away you
talking about the program I'm talking
about um you know we're at 009 page 777
um there was a little bit of money
before it's just been xed out entirely
now um it was a small amount I guess it
was mainly all General funds small
amount in actual FY 24 yeah
okay we can check what that is we can
research that's okay than you it's not a
budgeted amount it would be something
extraordinary probably some
administrative cost or something that we
were able to build Federal Highway for
or something like or federal government
for up okay
yeah
2916 is public
transportation it is primarily funded
with
federal funds
massively there's only a small portion
of it that is General
funded because the administrator is
split uh 5050 with railroad which is not
um federally
eligible so a lot of this is the pass
through FTA funds that goes to the um
um local Transit providers and if um and
and um again it doesn't it doesn't show
here because it was a general fund
appropriation last year but um typically
in that uh class line on the on page
779 073 grants for non-federal that is
generally the the local the local match
um if if there was we mentioned you know
last bium there was a general funded
match of $1.8 million that that helped
with the local match for this um the
$200,000 that that's shown there is just
the um some of the local match that
comes in for the bus the bus services
that the bus actual purchases that we
fund to right did you say that rail is
not included under this that's correct
the the only thing that's railing here
is there's one administrator that that
handles both rail Road and Transit and
they're not federally eligible on the
rail side so we have to split that cost
and so it that's where you see the
general funds for that follow up why
would that not be federally funded do
you know it wouldn't be federally funded
by FTA so so Federal Transit
Administration only funds Transit not
Railroad and and F doesn't fund that at
all so it would but okay thank you
and I think to answer your question
primarily the railroads in in New
Hampshire are not are not um like mass
transit railroads they're not like the
the TM Boston they're much more freight
Freight railroads
so thank you Mr chair um apologies for
being late I would have been here early
even though I misread the schedule but I
had to turn around cuz my I left
something at home that I shouldn't have
I apologize um on line 72 the federal
grants um there is some uh you know
lumpiness in 2024 2025 it's uh around 9
million in 24 and 13.2 in 25 and then it
settles to around 12 can you just give
me a bit of an idea of why the uh you
know roller coaster ride for the lack of
a better word I believe and Sh you can
correct me if I'm wrong I believe that
is that reflects the residual uh effects
of some of the uh ARA funds or or other
Federal um um emergency relief funds
that came postco is that is that true
Shelley Winters is our director of
Aeronautics Rail and Transit good
morning uh yes we'll be coming off of
the increase from some of the initial
arpa and iig funds and we also have some
cyclical purchases of replacement
Vehicles so there's some spikes based on
some Capital procurements that go
through this accounting unit and the the
federal
funds thank you so nothing really
unexpected just the end of oura and a
bit of a you know for the lack of better
word seasonal or less than cyclical Rec
cyclical purchases and we will be
settling into that 12 you know million
more or less going forward we don't
expect corre a lot of variation there
correct it's based on the our prognosis
of what the formula funds will be sure
thank you really appreciate it thank you
thank you before you continue I'm just
trying to make sure I get in the right
place here so looking back at
your slides o
sorry press the wrong
button this is we're going back to the
the budget review by division
Aeronautics R and Transit that's what
you're talking about that unfunded State
Transit is this 217
line the what you call it there the uh
Grant non-federal
is that what you were time that to
correct correct so actually would be
accounting unit
2916 class 73 oh it is the next one over
okay that was what I was wondering oh
I'm sorry I missed your question well no
no that's where I had it and then you
talk then you started talking about
arrow and I got okay so BL does belong
the next one thank you yeah
correct if you have any I need any
additional information about the impacts
of the L that Transit operating match
I'm happy to expound upon that if if
desired yeah Mr chair I'd love to hear
about uh what our regions can expect um
for the loss of funding thank you so we'
we've reached out and I know we know
there's a special session set up Friday
where the transit agencies and and their
passengers likely will come and speak to
that we've done some early Outreach so
with the loss of approximately $1.7
million of the general fund match as the
commissioner said that helps leverage uh
a one for one a 50-50 match with FTA
funds we can expect that it's going to
be a loss of about 3 point $7 million of
of funds to help fund Transit so we're
expecting that there'll be a loss of
service to the residents of the state
there'll be some Roots that'll be cut
whether that's Saturday service in one
Community whether it's night service in
another Community whether it's a shop or
Shuttle or a demand response service
that only goes to a remote Community
once or twice a week that may cease Al
together whether it's a connecting
service from Claremont to Lebanon to the
to the VA um instead of six trips a day
going down to two trips a day those are
some of the impacts that the local
Transit agencies are currently um
scrambling to look into and we'll come
to the table Friday with some more um
more information on but certainly we
expect there to be federal funds left on
the table we expect there to be an
impact to the traveling public who's
using this to get to jobs get to medical
appointments get to um nutrition get to
recreational so we see there to likely
be an impact to quality of life for the
residents that are served and in in many
cases depend solely on public transit to
get them where they need to be again we
think the transit agencies will be able
to do a a much better job of um
articulating those impacts to their
local communities but this will affect
10 public transit agencies throughout
the state uh it may require them to try
to liquidate their um Staffing Resources
to try to find local funds to supplant
this likely they will not be very
fruitful in those Endeavors so it will
um be a loss of service and probably a
loss of of time and resources to to try
to supplant these missing
funds representative M yes thank you um
and I know this is near impossible to
quantify but I imagine do you think they
will have more information um you did a
great job of listing the personal impact
that that'll have on this and you know
and talking about tens of thousands of
people I'm imagining um but it would be
nice if not impossible to also get the
financial impact of what it does to the
state for people who can't get to can't
get to a job for the sake of this you
know the the the income that's lost to
them the income that's lost to the
community because they've lost their
income the cost of the state around
Social Services um in terms of being
able to get to a medical facility for
something simple as opposed to waiting
until because they can't get there until
it becomes an emergency room um and
experience and I know know the New
Hampshire Transit Association and the
the 10 affected providers are working to
do that again some of these things are
diff difficult to to quantify and and
try to figure out how many missed
medical appointments and how many new
ambulance calls do that result in um how
many people may lose their job because
of their inability and I so I think they
have a better handle currently on the
internal impacts there were a system
that was trying to be wage competitive
with CDL drivers who now figures they
will not be able to have that CDL wage
increase and then they're now worried
about losing drivers to competitive
markets and that may also have further
service reductions so again I know they
have an internal handle and they're
trying to coales as a group for Friday
to try to bring some um impacts and
prognostications without um being too um
you know trying to oversee it or be too
outlandish with their inferences but
that's their intention on Friday I
believe thank you you're welcome
the next Au is uh 2931 it's railroad
that the administration of the railroad
program at dot the funding for
that is primarily uh General funds and
um we also have we do similar to in this
uh accounting unit as we did with the
uas position in that we share resources
and so we share two um FTE with Highway
design
I believe they are railroad engineer
positions correct one is a railroad
engineer position and the other one
deals with um mostly railroad as utility
as Crossing or um with Crossing um
projects that we have or if they're
Paving projects that have a railroad
interface so there's that Highway um
overlap and and kind of cross-section of
of the
department and and again this was set up
to to um mitigate some of the uh general
fund usage year you can see that we have
a little bit of federal funds F this is
the only F reimbursement that we are
eligible for and that is tied to out of
state
travel the rest of it is General
funds 2934 the railroad rehab loan um uh
this is set by um RSA 228 uh
66a it allows for loans to be available
to railroads for
rehabilitation currently it's primarily
the Cog Railway that has these loans uh
but it's not restricted to only the
C and it is a revolving fund if I oh if
I may ask really quickly um is it a loan
taken by a private
organization I'm just trying to
understand then why the uh you know 165
shows up in our budget
165,000 so uh under statute there are
certain classifications of of railroads
class three railroads in the Cog
railroad that can apply for this
revolving Loan Fund then we issue the
loan the the state goes out to bond and
then the uh repayment to the the
principal um in the interest is what
shows back up here in
2934 so basically we're just receiving
the money from the private entity and
then paying it to the we are the
intermediary and just responsible for
managing it correct and uh
okay this is why we have a matching
source of funds and then the Deb service
to other agencies so it's a zero sum
game more or less for the Department
thank
you isn't some of this
money since the state owns all the
railroad tracks when somebody wants to
run a train on them they have to pay the
state then we end up virtually giving
them everything back to repair the
tracks right uh so yeah so the the is
not owned by the state or the Department
of Transportation they've been the last
the recipient the last probably three
rounds so they're making that investment
in their privately owned infrastructure
and repaying US private railroads um
that own active trackage in the state
are also um allowed we have not in
recent years in my probably 14 years in
in rail had anyone who operates on a
state Own Line put in for so we haven't
been using a loan to essentially fix our
own infrastructure um in the past I
understand and we've had tenant
railroads who have applied for funds to
create sidings to go to a shipper or
receiver and they have constructed those
on private property so we have not sort
of used it as a loan for ourselves we
rely on the special railroad fund which
is accounting T accounting unit 2991
which we'll get to
shortly which funds are so we're not
talking about we haven't got to that one
yet of the tracks we own yes right
that's correct yeah thank
you two 936 is reimbursable maintenance
and repair it is a placeholder it's a
placeholder for storm damage and federal
reimbursements that would come through
that and primarily that would be FEMA
it's just a
placeholder last year you can see that
we spent
$77,000
there 2937 compensation and benefits um
so these class lines are are sometimes a
little vague so 042 the class line is
for retiree Health those are new charges
that have been assessed to the general
fund that that's why you see nothing for
actual expend expenditures on in 24 and
25 um we have a placeholder for
unemployment compensation because we
don't we never know what those things
are going to be but we need the the line
and then workers compensation um which
is pro which is a number provided by uh
administrative
Services source of that is General funds
special railroad funds right and this is
what represented while I think you're
referring to so this is for state owned
railroads um it is the we collect uh
railroad crossing and Freight fees and
the revenues are used to maintain and
operate the lines The Operators get the
funds to do so shall
we sure so this uh the special railroad
fund is set up under statute
22868 establishes the special Ro Fund in
22869 um is prescriptive in how the
funds can be used 20% of the revenue
that we receive from our tenant
railroads in the form of a user fee um
are paid back proportionally to the
municipalities through which the
railroads operate so the department Nets
essentially 80% of the railroad user
fees um derived from our tenant
railroads those user fees are
essentially percents of their gross
operating Revenue uh for our four
Freight operators we get 5% of their
annual gross Freight operating revenue
is a user fee paid to the state under
contract those uh Freight operators are
required to put a minimum of 20% of
their gross operating back into the
maintenance of the line so the state is
essentially um netting 25% of their
gross Freight Revenue either in uh a fee
paid to the state that goes through this
budget or in the Improvement in state
owned infrastructure for our two tourist
Excursion railroads roads we have we get
receive 10% of their annual gross ticket
revenues and 10% of their annual um
gross revenue is then put back in So for
for those um two entities 20% of gross
operating is paid to or invested in
state infrastructure we take the
remainder of the user fees that we net
as well as payments for um driveway
Crossings leases and and other uses or
impacts to state owned railroad property
and again through Force account we go to
governor and coun we use our tenant
railroads to make those improvements to
the railroad system whether it's ties
surfacing drainage cover Bridges things
of that nature we partner with these six
tenant railroads to maintain the state's
infrastructure as best we can with the
revenue that we generate from use of our
property thank you so quick question you
were saying that we are requiring the
railroads to spend 20% of their grow to
maintain the rail and whatnot how close
are we looking at the work that they are
doing and the costs that they are
accounting for to make sure they are
reasonable rather than on exercising
Creative Accounting there yeah so good
question so we have a railroad
operations engineer position that's
budgeted in so there's no State staff
budgeted in the um special railroad fund
the railroad staff is all in 2931 which
we had previously looked at there's one
railroad operations engineer in
accounting unit 2931 that person becomes
sort of a clerk of of the works on the
projects and they go out and oversee the
projects and um look at the plans in
advance they talk and meet with the
contractors to make sure they're
qualified we have another staff member
that is the project manager the contract
manager for these contracts and they go
out and do annual audits to look at all
the Maintenance of Way work that is done
and we require in advance what their
rate fee for the year will be for their
for in their laborer um for rental of
any track equipment that will be used or
yellow um construction equipment so we
compare that to um if we were going out
to bid for some of our own projects what
are the rates that we would get so we we
do it a multitude of ways thank you so
much that's an excellent answer I
appreciate it thank you
thanks and that is the end of the first
division the second division that we
have is the administration division the
first Au is
2938 2938 is Debt Service it pays for
the bonding of our fund 30 capital
projects or the projects that get
approved in
hb25 um the timing of of the payments
here depends really on Treasury bonding
and the timing of the do project
expenditures and when they
occur and that is 100% um Highway
funding and I would say we've made some
assumptions for the for the budget as
far as what the capital budget um would
would sustain so um I I know that's uh
you know another another committee but
there is a there is a Nexus there that
um that we'll be discussing as
well thank you in regards to this amount
of uh debt payments that we are
making do we have an estimate on whether
the you know current amount of PR
principle that we ow is supposed to uh
start decreasing at some point or is it
kind of a rolling situation would we
keep adding new loans as fast as we pay
the old
ones it's more of a bigger thing yeah I
know it's a complex question the best
the overall capital budget gets rolled
into the overall state state debt so so
the loans I think are a maximum of 10
years so they're constantly rolling
right because every two years you get
new capital projects s so you're paying
for those and you're paying off older
ones so I would say that on your in your
uh question it would be ongoing rolling
thank you so
much but I know that discussion when it
gets to the capital budget and
discussing that um the overall Outlook
from the from from from the state's
perspective I think the Department of
Treasury would have a much better handle
on that overall outstanding debt and
principle and stuff so yeah
transfers to other agencies
2939 these are items that the dot pays
to other
agencies are you okay I'm
sorry yeah thank you this is a small
amount but I know that there have been
people who have cons they have concerns
about the dams and um functioning and
you know re Rehabilitation of some of
the dams you have got a little bit here
it's over you know someplace else but
can you speak to um the impact that has
on you because some of those if the Dam
breaks it affects the road and just the
Nexus around uh transportation's role
with Dam
maintenance um I I would say we have a
fairly
um limited limited role with the overall
Dam maintenance there are some
facilities that that that we have um
roadway embankments that are
um classified as as a as a dam there's
some in the Sea Coast the you know
whatever I forget the pond there and and
and Ry is is one and uh other ones but
there uh so so in those situations where
um we're held to the same Dam damn owner
rules that that that others are and we
managed those uh specifically um where
where they interact our facilities but
the broader
uh picture of Dam dam maintenance I
think is under um Department of
Environmental Services
yeah um I'd like to bring your attention
to um class line 027 transferred to oit
the reduction here is really a reduction
uh to meet budget targets but it also
includes two lost positions um it's two
embedded it positions at do so dot will
feel the loss of that
just a quick question you are saying
that it's a loss of two positions but
I'm looking at the reduction that's
significantly less than the cost of two
positions I'm assuming there were some
other increases that offset some of the
loss yes thank
you um a transfer to other state
agencies 049 is the employee assistance
program and the 00 four under revenue is
an embedded it position at the turnpike
system which has to pay for its
own and the remainder is Highway
funded general fund uh overhead 2940
this really are payments made to
administrative services for services
provided um both direct and indirect so
transfers plant and property is rent for
the Morton Building and um indirect
costs are the administrative um Services
we call it the
swap but it's indirect Services provided
by administrative
services and if I may very quickly I
apologize obviously understand what
indirect costs are in general but yes in
this particular case um it just seems to
be quite a hefty amount of indirect cost
compared with the rest of the unit can
you give me a bit of an understanding of
what
exactly would go into those indirect
costs for that particular unit so
indirect costs from from the Department
of administrative Services would would
include Staffing and services provided
by um the department of uh the division
of personnel the uh the accounting
Bureau the um folks manag purchasing
property anything that would provide a
service overall to all
agencies oh uh plants and properties
probably in there
yeah and that is 100% Highway funds
right but that I mean that that
that assessment is not unique to the do
I think that that that assessment that
Das does is is
uh to all agencies I know I'm asking you
guys about your share of it yes uh can I
also ask about the U significant uh
change from 26 to 27 in the 064 line the
benefits retired and so on I mean that's
a million dollars jump again budget
numbers that were given to us and do you
know where they come from in terms of
how they were projected is that the
estimate from the retirement system
what is the source to the best of your
knowledge of the
estimate we don't get any information ah
thank you what's m retial
well I would refer that to to
administrative Services when they do the
presentation
yeah so just to clarify retire health so
that those would be numbers that risk
management at admin services with their
presumably Actuarial estimates for the
next two years will bill out to all the
agencies of retirees in the system and
and probably anticipated new
retirements During the period so that
that is a Statewide
um calculation that's done and then
allocated to each
agency thank you right
3038 is the executive office and that
funds the execu office um so funds the
Commissioners the directors and staff
except for the director of of um Dart uh
Shell's position who's funded by General
funds and here we have Blended uh the
revenues for several of the accounting
units that you're going to see are going
to be Blended um these accounting units
will receive um indirect costs uh
indirect revenue from turnpikes the
turnpike system from the general funds
They will receive indirect federal funds
and they will rece and Highway funds uh
finally 3040 is the office of asset
managements you'll notice the positions
here so if you look at the bottom you'll
see position count increase it's really
not an increase in positions it's a it's
a shifting of positions from turnpikes
to
camps from in the last budget cycle in
the last last budget cycle but the the
the costs weren't allocated right so
we're making a correction on where they
belong but it's not an increase in
headcount from from Turnpike two from
the turnpike system to um amps this this
accounting
unit right which find Highway basically
yes Blended
the next item is a new accounting unit
for us it's 3174 it is the safety office
um we have elevated the safety the
safety program at do
to um to highlight the importance of
safety and so the funding for this uh
accounting unit has been split out of
another uh unit it's Highway design 30
25 so 3025 we took some of the we took
some of the expenses um some of the
positions eight of the positions and
shifted them into their own accounting
unit we move to the division of
finance division of finance
uh we've already had these conversations
about the the unfund of positions Etc
mhm um and the funding is still the same
except we do have some agency income and
that is just print shop revenue from um
from billing uh Public
Works we move to the division of policy
and
administration and the first Au is 2056
the office of federal compliance or
access opport opportunity and compliance
I'm sorry what page are we on I'm sorry
page
793 that division the division only had
one Bureau so we move to it the next
one office of access opportunity and
compliance um fully Federal uh it's
Federal funded and uh indirect
funded thehr Bureau
again nothing uh un stop me if you need
to um employee training employee
training we see some significant
variance because we shifted uh the
funding of the training program to
Federal the federal program um the
federal uh fhwa has a 504e program that
allows for training travel subscription
and dues and so instead of using Highway
funds primarily we're using federal
funds right
okay and well we've also ramped this up
to really focus a lot on employee
development um and uh hopefully
Recruitment and Retention as well too
so and we move to the Operations
Division you want me to go through the
yeah okay what account I'll give uh
Danielle a break what what account is
that pardon me which account 2928 2928
so this is the uh we're moving into the
uh uh division of
operations uh this org is uh is where we
bucket all of the winter winter
maintenance costs
um again this is this is one of the this
is one of the areas where I believe we
are uh purposefully un underfunding from
from what we feel that we would
typically um typically need um if you
look at um
it's spread
across several several class lines but
um again we have purposely kind of
underfunded this area to to meet budget
targets but this is this is where um
ideally we would we would propose to
fund the uh winter maintenance incentive
program uh to uh have have volunteers to
continue that would be shown typically
in um that class 17 employee special
payments um again we believe that that
should be about $2.8 million more than
what is what is budgeted there um and
then the various class lines for current
expense for
leases um slow so class on 17 and we're
under window maintenance correct yes yes
turn down to it so that shows not a very
large a big big decrease no if you look
at the actual if you look at the 24
actuals that's high and then it goes way
down yes right that funds that funds the
retention incentive program so so that
program is is happening and it happened
in 24 we had we came to uh get
permission for that and so it is funded
there but we could not fund it in 20 in
26 27 so that's why the numbers are are
much different that retention incentive
hits several class lines but it hits CL
uh class 17 the most but it also hits of
course class 60 which is taxes and
benefits and it also hits class
49 which is uh to pay for other
employees from other agencies who come
and help support winter maintenance as
well it hits those three class
lines so I just point that out this was
one of our priorities we can make
recommendations there isn't uh but but
those are some of the um you know
additional needs that we'd like have
identified and would like
consideration
um so overall the um and and I think on
the bottom line of when you look at the
total um total there too if you look at
the fy2 24 expenses of around 40 million
compared to what we're we're budgeting
of around 30 30.4
30.5 um if it was a if it was a very
light winter in those years that that
might be adequate but um we we we know
particularly based on you know FY 245
for example adjusted
authorized uh that was $32 million we
know that we have uh gone to fiscal for
winter maintenance transfers of around
$10 million so you know that actual
number is up around probably $42 million
in terms of actual expenditures so it's
an indication it's it's a it's a it's a
it's a range it's a ballpark of of I
think where uh this org is uh
underfunded so and the other the other
two class lines that that are typically
underfunded are 20 class 20 and class 20
is used to purchase salt and sand and
liquids uh for surface treatment and
class 22
which is to pay for the rented uh
contractor equipment which makes up
about 48% of Dot's
Fleet
22 thank
you repres hack and Phillips quick
followup thank you Mr chair um could you
describe a little bit about that 48% of
rented Fleet what are we talking about
um things that we have have to rent
because
our uh schedule of Investments on our
own Fleet is behind so we have to find
replacements or how maybe just some more
context pleas I think the context we we
are generally staffed for for summer
maintenance uh we augment our winter
maintenance needs with with hired plows
so um about 5050 or 48% um if if you
notice when when you when when you're
out in a storm or something you'll
you'll probably see a orange dot plow if
there's a if there's a secondary or an
auxiliary plow it's probably a uh a non-
orange plow which is which is someone
we've hired to to plow for us um is that
Affair Dave Rodriguez our uh assistant
commissioner former director of
operations and and can speak to that but
I think it's primarily we don't staff
for full weight di mens we rely on the
hired plows that's correct and that that
has been how the department efficiently
provides winter maintenance for
um the history of the the department
we've always relied on hired equipment
to supplement um pieces that we don't
own and in the case of this winter
winter plow trucks and others we we rent
um trucks with operators to provide that
service thank you would it be fair to
say that because of the seasonal SL
shortterm needs for winter maintenance
this is the most costeffective model
regardless of how much money we'd have
for the budget absolutely yes that's
very fair to say thank
you I'm Murray thank you very much um
yeah we had a non- orange plow come
through Newcastle which C which was my
phone was ringing off the hook as was
the chief of police's phone was ringing
off the hook oh know cost quite the stir
so there's a slight increase in the
highway fun overall the
253 and here you know there's your $2
million
um uh reduction um I'm just curious if
overall if you can provide you know a
larger picture of where you're using the
additional 2 million that's coming in
for I guess is
that class line yeah H I'm sorry you
know I just your rent of maintenance is
so critical and you're reducing that by
the 2 million overall you've got um a
slight increase in I guess this is going
to be
2027 of 253 million on this I'm looking
on this thingy here
um so if you can just tie in where that
you know I it's a very slight increase
in the overall effect but how have you
made the decision to reduce this as a um
with that slight increase you know what
I'm asking I do now okay thank you um I
think i' we may have to do a little bit
more digging to get you a straight
answer on that it is it is a lar we are
a large organization yeah uh yeah I
guess what I'm looking for is uh this is
is a priority decision and so just it
doesn't have to be very detailed but um
just your way of thinking about how you
have to disperse limited funds right
certainly
um moving on the next Bureau uh uh 35
The Mechanical Services Bureau um again
that is uh that is when when we talked
about um Le
um primarily in the class line of um 030
equipment new replacement um we would uh
ideally like to see about $1 million a
year is what we feel the uh ongoing uh
Fleet replacement schedule warrants um
you can see we're scheduled we we have
budgeted for about uh half that roughly
a little bit more in 20
2027 um and I would again point out it's
not reflected in the uh adjusted
authorized or in the 2024 actual
expenses because um we did have a
general fund appropriation of about 4.8
million at the end of last budget in
recognition of of the continued need to
uh not put uh you know you know not to
continue to incur def deferred
maintenance of of the fleet past budgets
we've put a lot of effort through
capital budget Appropriations and other
things to um to um uh focus on the fleet
and and
counter many years of of disinvestment
and deferred maintenance in in the fleet
so we've we've got it into a uh a pretty
good a good place and we would hate to
see us lose lose ground
so we have made some uh some thoughtful
increases here in class 20 there is
really we're we're seeing 7% increases
in part costs um and we need to maintain
a equipment and so we've made some
increases there and then in
um in the class 37 line you see a jump
there and that really is for some
specialized diagnostic software that
will that will make will help us be more
efficient um right now we're using 11
pieces of software to diagnose equipment
and there's there's um there's a product
out there that can combine all of those
into one and to have one piece of
equipment and so that's what you're
looking at there
right any moving ahead the next uh organ
or unit 3007 is the Highway Maintenance
Bureau um again that is all that is uh a
big part of our operations uh budget is
is the Highway Maintenance Bureau um one
point I would point out if you look at
uh line 029
uh inter agency
transfers you'll notice that expense
there in
2627 again that is we we discussed the
uas position and the highway funds that
are going to fund that position that is
where that's the tie that's where it's
reflected on on the on the highway fund
side of the of the
um of the budget so that expense is
reflected in agency income um where that
position is
located um
and again
um overall a generally kind of uh flat
uh you know flat budget all those all
those class lines primarily to um again
meet meet budget targets um but this
would be probably an area where um you
know we didn't identify additional needs
per se
but um as as as we meet budget Targets
this is where uh you know some of the
areas that in terms of deferred
maintenance that we would uh ideally
like to do more um we are restricted by
by the budget here we're on 3007 right
correct so this's going to jump from 24
actual and then on in your expenses
right that's correct that reflects
mostly the changes what you see that is
is in uh class 10 which which shows
vacancies right so it would be in 10 and
60 primarily that that goes into our you
know the lapse that that we experience
every because of those High vacancy
rates representative Roy can you explain
did I miss something under benefits here
it went from 15 up to 24 and then up to
25 million under 060 we're in Highway
Maintenance yep yeah again again that's
a direct reflection of the of the uh 25%
vacancy rate that we have so the actual
expenditures in
24 uh were only $15 million because we
had a 25% vacancy rate um if we were
fully staffed um in the permanent
budgeted positions uh it should be um
more in line with the $25 million that's
shown in FY 25 26 and 27
so and the 26 and 27 amounts also
include large increases in those
benefits that we were
provided so it's compounded yeah
incentives is that or benefit increases
being what I'm not sure I understand I
think health insurance is I think the
largest increase that is seen and
reflected in the 26 and 27 budgets okay
all right thank you is that is that your
question what class 60 comprises or yeah
yeah so it's taxes and any employee
benefits paid by the state yeah which is
primarily the health insurance tax
health insurance the portion of
retirement yeah
primarily um and again back in the
source of funds it is
um it is uh you know primarily Highway
fund there's a small amount of agency
income uh some sponsorship Revenue um
that that comes from
um uh the uh vehicle service Patrol that
that we that we
operate the next uh or 2008 Bridge
maintenance Bureau uh Bridge maintenance
is our Bureau that maintains uh the
existing state uh bridges in this uh in
this org there was one uh position one
full-time position that that was um
unfunded to to
um to meet budget targets um again a
relatively flat uh uh flat budget all
the way across with some um specific uh
needs identified uh again I think you
had called it Danielle the
um thoughtful increases in certain lines
as are specific um items to be addressed
for example uh class 30 new equipment
replacement um there's a slight increase
there in 26 uh we know there are some uh
specific uh trailer compress trailer
compressors that that we're budgeting
replacements for things like that um we
have increased class 50 a little bit uh
in anticipation of uh hopefully trying
to have some
um uh temporary uh hires or uh and and
fill some and and help offset some of
the some of the
vacancies we in Bridge maintenance yes
yep 3 801 oh there's the increase okay
yeah up and down probably probably the
largest increase you'll see is in class
103 and that is for bridge washing
primarily right but the numbers seem be
bouncing around so class 5th you just
mentioned down from FY 24 actual to 2 uh
4 to 25 which I get but then up and then
back down again in
27 am I reading that right up to 80 27
is down to meet budget targets
right okay great but what because 26 you
figur You' didn't need to or something
we would know we would still need it but
we still had to meet a Target so we had
to cut something okay so you did it in
just the final
right we hope we won't have to need them
if you know primarily we use these to to
supplement vac ancies so if we could
hire we wouldn't need as many temps
right so we could be also hopeful in 27
that we wouldn't need as much I get now
to you okay yeah
okay um and again the primary source of
funds there is um um federal funds and
Highway funds primarily Highway funds
there are uh work efforts that bridge
maintenance does on federal aid elig Bri
federal aid eligible bridges that we
direct fund uh those eligible activities
for um as well as some um indirect cost
recoveries from Turnpike and Inter
agency transfers that so is that kind of
a matching funds thing between Federal
and Highway or they're just totally
unrelated you get the highway funds you
get the federal funds for whatever you
want and then you also have Highway
funds or something else typically most
maintenance typically federal funds
would would not support maintenance
activities uh so in this account you're
just getting federal funds some of the
bridge work that we do Bri Bridges the
focus on on on Bridges the bridge
maintenance does some of the
rehabilitation and stuff is federally
eligible type of work for example on the
Highway Maintenance side most Highway
Maintenance activities are not federal
aid eligible the the plowing the
ditching the the maintaining of the
system the bridge maintenance activities
working on specific federal aid eligible
Bridges uh and the work that they do to
bring them back into service whether
it's a a deck replacement or some of the
the other um work is is eligible so we
take advantage and and try to um um
apply those funds as appropriate but
those funds in this particular case
don't require a match that's basically
funds you can get that apply to certain
kinds of things that federal funds are
available for well the federal funds do
require a match but but when you look at
the uh High f is that the highway fund
match that's what I was asking it's
compr it's it's included in that okay
you
yeah the match typically isn't as much
of a of a of a of an issue because it's
being done with Department forces so all
of our Personnel time and and things
like that would would go toward the
would go toward the
match
yeah yes representative haen Phillips
thank you I was just looking at line uh
400 for construction repair materials
and it looks like there was a pretty big
swing upward in 26 27 could you give us
a little background I misspoke when I
said it was line 103 it really is line
400 I
apologize I did the same thing yesterday
so that is one of the things with with
um we should be washing Bridges washing
the salt off washing the material off
quite frequently again with some of the
vacancies and stuff we um have not been
able to achieve those targets uh this
past year we had uh we had done a uh a
cont a bridge washing contract and
that's what that um line item um
reflects
to contract some of that
workout the next uh organizational code
on page 802 is our traffic operations
Bureau um again they take care of all
the signs all the signals all of the all
of the
striping uh along along the uh along the
state highways
um there are some again some thoughtful
changes as there are specific items that
we're looking to uh address uh in in the
budget for example
um I I I look at uh
um technology Hardware class 37 there is
a uh an increase there there are some
specific um you know equipment updates
for remote accessing of uh uh traffic
signals and some of the software to
support that that that is contained in
in that um we also have an increase in
class 46 um in the consultant line item
uh again to meet some of our obligations
to review
um uh driveway applications and and
permit applications and some traffic
impact studies um we do not again with
the vacancies necessarily have the
Personnel to keep up with that so we do
bring on some consultant help to um
perform those reviews as well what line
number was that again that was line 46
under Consultants thank
you
yeah um was there a question or well
there wasn't but then I see I'm looking
line 50 I was getting to that yeah on
page 803 yeah
um again that that's uh you know per
personal service those are the temporary
hires typically we would we would hire
uh a bunch a lot of seasonal help to
help uh uh man the uh the striping
vehicles that that that stripe the
highways through through the summer
months um we still have it uh budgeted
in the ideal but if you look at the
actual expenses in in 2024 we have been
very um we have been very uh we have not
been very successful in in trying to
hire seasonal help for for the wages
that that we pay so we're competing with
McDonald's and and others and Dunkin
Donuts that uh uh you know paying more
than than than than uh than the state is
offering um we still get the work done
we are pressing in into service other uh
Highway Maintenance folks to uh to do
that seasonal work again it's at the
expense of some maintenance activities
that they would that they would
typically be doing um but um but that's
that's what that line implies and we've
continued to budget it with the uh with
with the anticipation and the Hope in
our efforts that we would still try to
recruit and still try to hire that
seasonal Health to staff those um
activities but um
historically we haven't been very
successful in the last few years with
that and then again it is a split funded
if you look at the funding there is
inter agency transfers for uh supporting
the work that traffic agent does
primarily on the on the turnpike system
agency and directs uh and again some of
the federal funds um again Federal
direct and indirect uh some of the
direct federal funds that we apply to
Traffic Division
uh the striping activities uh we have
categorized that we've classified that
as as a as a safety Improvement to keep
up with uh um the visibility of the line
striping so that has been
um approved as a federal aid eligible
expense so we direct Bill Federal
Highway uh for those uh striping
activities on federal aid eligible
highways
so the next line L uh 31 331 on page 804
is reimbursable maintenance and and
repair um again it's where we kind of
bucket some of those uh some of those uh
some of those costs for that uh
maintenance and repair that ideally will
be reimbursable storm events uh FEMA
reimbursement things like things like
that
um and the revenue is a placeholder so
we don't know what we would get for
federal revenue so the revenue is parked
in 005 but it'll probably be a split um
0000 I think that's a D um really is
more FEMA it's mostly FEMA
related
yeah moving ahead uh on page 805 um or
for asset maintenance and critical
repair this is the org to uh repair dot
assets that fall into uh disrepair or
fail um we have about um 90 uh Patrol
sheds and various facilities around the
state so this is uh where we uh would
fund things like heating systems or
other things like that and the
maintaining mainten M maintenance of our
own uh do
facilities
um and again that source of Revenue is
is
100% um
uh 100% Highway funds um again we have
limited things to meet budget budget
targets uh you look at FY 24 actual
expend expenditures um certainly some um
you know additional repairs for things
that had failed that that we had to um
that we had to take care
of uh uh org 352 at the bottom of that
page is our transportation systems
management and operations uh Bureau
um again relatively
um flat or modest uh increases as as we
look through um some of the individual
um class lines um and again this is
multif funded from uh a number of
different sources um there are inter
agency
transfers um because this is the trans
uh uh um traffic Management Center a lot
of their activity is focused on on the
freeway and Interstate systems uh so I
95 and the F Turnpike for example so um
uh per an Mo MOA internally about
49% of of this bureau's
um revenue is it comes from the turnpike
comes from the turnpike system for the
services that they provide monitoring
and overseeing the Turnpike
assets um moving on to page
807 uh org 355 is our inmate maintenance
crew um we do uh we do try to uh solicit
and and and utilize in inmate um
maintenance Crews typically for trash
collection uh or um tree clearing along
the highways things like that
um so yeah go ahead thank you with
regards to that uh I know you you're
trying to utilize um this opportunity is
there what would be the barriers for
increasing this opportunity I'm going
back to hear you talking about things
like striping the highway and some of
those sorts of activities is that a job
that would not be open to an inmate
maintenance kind of crew for what you
know for a variety of reasons are there
other opportunities here to expand and
take advantage of the you know not take
advantage opportunity you know I don't
know if it's volunteer per se but uh
there is most of these costs here
associated with the supervision of those
uh maintenance crew so that the the um
the uh class 50 the Personnel Service is
to is to hire and and pay for a a guard
to come with them the class 22 is for a
a a um a a van to transport them but um
do you know Alexis I know a little bit
very good Alexis Martin is our director
of policy and administration good
morning one of the barriers is um that
many um of these individuals do not have
a
license so they're unable to drive um we
uh do also uh in the past we have done
um a uh you know prisoner to fulltime
Employee Program through the Bureau of
traffic um has not been successful as we
hoped um we did have uh a a couple of
individuals who came through um secured
full-time employment and then moved on
um to other things which was great um so
we do do still have that relationship
with the transitional work center um and
only um certain uh uh offenses uh are
allowed over um but uh something we
continue to do um they send us the staff
and we continue to work with them and
and offer them a full-time opportunity
if they are
interested is there a skill issue
involved in this and is there also an
issue of um people who whether you know
whether or not they can belong to a
union whether there's union workers
involved um so anyone uh part-time or
full-time um can join the union if they
so choose um the skill issue is many of
these Physicians are um called a uh uh
how we maintain or one so the
qualifications are uh three months of
employment and pretty much anything um
and then we skill you up through um
through the process usually over the
summer
striping um participating in those
activities coning um those kinds of
things so um when in the past when the
part-time employment for striping was
really a pipeline to full-time
employment for seasonal worker
um so they would get some experience in
maintenance under their belt and then be
able to come on full-time staff to the
Highway Maintenance group um and become
an HM uh one or two hopefully within a
year and then move throughout um the
maintenance
Bureau good thank
you on page 808 the next uh item
uh
366 is salted Wells this pays for uh
replacement of contaminated Wells this
has been uh generally
um a a a a set amount that that we've
have put aside to to address this issue
uh I know costs are increasing and uh
you know we are concerned of of you know
um uh increasing backlogs of these of
these of these needs but this was an
established program to address an issue
that had uh been been been um identified
number number of years ago we've
continued to fund it at about this about
this level in every budget um but but um
I I know we do have a uh growing backlog
of of of needs um that get identified
so but again this was set fairly level
to meet meet budget
targets uh or 30 3198 is a fuel
distribution um the Department of
Transportation runs runs the state's uh
fuel uh fueling system U this provides
do this provides fuel to do other state
agencies the university system um and
there is another line item while I get
to Beyond which is related with the
municipal fuel because uh uh
municipalities also utilize the state um
fueling
Network um and again just generally
um generally level level um level level
funded or reduced to meet budget targets
uh and um a big part of this Revenue
comes from the agency income there at
the bottom in 009 which is uh you know
revenue from the other state agencies
Department of Safety or others that are
using the state fuel Network as well as
our own um fuel usage there and um the
highway
funds code four uh 5032 is our oversized
and overweight permitting section this
is a revolving fund for um for the
operation and administration of our
permit section um so it's s supported by
the fees that that we pay that that
people pay for uh for their oversiz and
overweight permits um and and that's
shown at the bottom there uh the source
of funds is is that revolving
fund code 5034 is for our lift bridge
operators um they maintain the bridges
and and the lift Bridges particularly in
Portsmouth uh the Sarah along bridge and
the Memorial
Bridge um just want on my mind you
mentioned fees so there are some fees
that you all control and set up and that
sort of thing such as the over oversized
overweight permitting fee yes could you
just provide us not right now but a list
of what those fees are that you're you
guys deal with and control and and when
the last time was they were rais and if
you have any thoughts for raising them
that sort of thing okay certainly
it safe to assume that goes into the Gen
the highway fund well for particularly
the over size and overweight that goes
into a revolving fund that's used just
to support that activity okay but it's
the same sort of it's a dedicated fund
that could be it is a a statutory
dedicated fund yes but it could be used
ways that we've discussed previously
okay thank you
represent Murray now just a quick
question informational and I won't
mention the little elephant in the room
but how many lift bridges are there in
the
state I believe there are
four there are four one
being elep little the elephant in the
room being Ry Newcastle Ry yeah yeah
right yeah yeah and it's funny you
looked at with uh if you look at uh
um you know some of the some of the
budget line and and that uh if you look
at uh class 50 Personnel Services you'll
see reduction from 26 to 27 that that's
a reflection of of the Hampton Harbor
Bridge uh the the the new uh fix ban
being being open and the and the lift
bridge going away there uh by
2027 that
yeah exactly right yeah and Counting
yeah representative d
does Maine participate in the
sarong quarter yes and if you look at
the uh uh uh the fund line underneath
that 005 the private local funds uh that
line represents the state of Maine's
share uh for the expenditures in in the
lift bridge operations thank you
right
um so that's the that that's uh that
covers the um
division of project uh division of
operations moving along to 812 we get
into our Bureau of uh I mean the
division of project development these
are the bureaus that um are responsible
for the planning design oversight of
construction of our of our of our
Highway
program
um uh starting off with the uh uh or
code
3021 the uh planning community
Assistance Bureau
um most of that is all relatively um you
know level funded or or reduced to um to
meet uh budget um to meet budget
constraints um a few specific line items
uh a little bit of an increase in in
class 50 uh on page 813 uh that is um
to address some expected
retirements and uh some some help in
helping transition those uh those
vacancies um we did eliminate two
full-time temporary positions there when
you look at class
59 um
otherwise um things are relatively level
and um again all of these project
development bureaus are are multif
funded uh with some
uh either Direct Federal fund billing
for the work that they do on on the
federal program or federal indirect
funds um as well as some Turnpike
indirect revenue for um for those
efforts uh that that are related to the
uh Turnpike
system the next uh or code 3025 is the
highway design Bureau
um this is this if you uh look at the
bottom there are eight View positions in
this or code uh we talked about the
safety section being moved to the um to
the commissioner's office this is the
your code where those positions came
from and some of those reductions um in
class 10 in class 60 uh and and along
there are reflected um here as well um
we did if you look at class 59 uh
reduction uh across there we eliminated
seven full-time temporary positions to
meet budget
targets um and at the very bottom in
code class 405 which is the Lilac
program I know I heard representative
wer ref reference the Lilac program um
that is funded uh with um um with
revenue from the from the conservation
plates that come to us for this activity
the change here is that uh it it it we
determined it was a better fit under our
Bureau of environment to put out the the
lilac program and manage the Lilac
program then in the Bureau of Highway
design so those um and in another or
code further further on our Bureau of
environment that program has been moved
to that so did you say there were some
positions that were moved and some that
were
reduced out of that total of yes the
eight the eight that were reduced were
were just moved so those eight positions
were the safety positions that were
moved the safety section to the
commissioner's office class 59 there's a
substantial reduction there those uh
class 59 represent uh temporary
full-time
positions um that uh that represents
seven full-time temporary positions that
have been
eliminated represent muray thank you
very much um at a higher level can you
just give an overview of how you
approach Highway design to put it in
base layman's terms what is left to
design
so
um I I guess I don't want to say what do
you what is left to design what what
they do the highways are here uh the
entrance ramps the exit ramps they're
here you know all that stuff is year so
um how do you plan forward for
additional Highway design sure and you
know where would a big part of it comes
from the from the 10-year plan the
10-year plan identifies uh project needs
uh throughout throughout the department
based on the federal revenue those could
be uh resurfacing projects Highway
reconstruction projects brid replacement
projects um intersection Improvement
projects uh safety related projects so
all of those um construction activities
um require design work somebody to put
um to figure out what what needs to be
done someone to manage the project
somebody to um you know put the contract
plans together uh advertise of
construction project uh so the highway
design Bureau primarily then is
responsible for overseeing all of that
design we're doing much more work with
uh with Consultants now um the
consultant cost are reflected under the
federal program but they the the direct
oversight by by the the highway design
Personnel yeah thanks for fleshing it
out because you know in reading that one
can just read it as new uh you know new
design projects and so thank you fill
that
okay yeah
right and again uh this org like most of
them are is is multi multif funded with
um inter agency transfers that's direct
labor from the uh indirect and direct
labor from the trp bike system
um agency indirect cost recoverables
where we uh look for reimbursement of
indirect costs and um you know we have
direct direct and indirect federal funds
budgeted here so um folks that are
working on federal aid eligible design
design projects they uh direct Bill to
those Federal Federal projects and that
um direct billing is reflected in in in
in this Revenue
line um on page 815 is our right of way
Bureau uh or 3028 those are the people
that uh manage all the State properties
and and acquire all of the uh necessary
property rights to uh support the
project development process and and
support the uh projects that that we are
doing um again generally level funded uh
a a few um te technology um Investments
and some new software Associated there
the equipment line uh our survey section
uh Works under the Bureau of uh R of way
survey instruments and stuff are are
typically fairly expensive uh and those
equipment um needs are reflected in that
class 30
line
um again this is an area where we have
eliminated two um temporary full-time
positions to meet budget targets that's
in class
59 uh and again the estimated source of
funds is multif funded with um um inter
agency transfers agency and direct
direct crost recovery federal funds and
Highway funds bu of uh the next code 30
3032 is our environmental Bureau they
oversee all of our permitting and
oversee all of the um all of our uh
Environmental Compliance for our federal
federal aid projects again mostly
generally uh level funded I had
referenced the Lilac program that shows
up here as we move that program to this
uh to this Bureau um and similarly
multif funded as well uh page 818 is the
bridge design Bureau um again those are
uh the folks that um design the bridge
projects and oversee our existing Bridge
section as well as all all the um
inspection activities for our state
Bridges um again generally level funded
a few specific line items class 38
technology soft Weare uh that represents
a purchase of um of a specific um ashto
Weare Bridge inspection and and
management software uh to do our Bridge
load ratings and uh manage uh the bridge
uh inventory
data
um and we've also um increased uh uh
class uh 46 to have some specific
consultant help in terms of uh uh
supporting the bridge inspection efforts
as
well and again class 39 class
59 uh those reductions again uh
represent the elimination of three
full-time uh temporary positions to meet
budget
targets um moving right along class 3034
on page 819 that's our materials and
research Bureau um this is an area in
class 10 you see some of the reductions
this this uh organization uh or unit um
we unfunded three full-time positions
here to meet budget targets so that
reduction is reflected there
um and that's the biggest change in that
Bureau um sure excuse me represent
hacken Phillips thank you Mr chair I'm
just wondering where what line were you
looking at for the three reductions you
were just speaking of Class 10 okay
thank you which is the direct labor it
doesn't show as much from the FY 25
authorized to FY 26 but but the but the
um
well I yeah I can see the the numbers
don't quite quite quite bear it out but
uh that was where three positions
because you have because you also have
in there you know like any raises that
people get
so yeah
um continuing on um page 821 is our uh
construction Bureau those are the people
that oversee out in the field all the
construction uh
activities um again generally um level
level funded throughout there that's
another area um it does typically have a
fairly High overtime rate in class
18 um again most of that work is driven
by the contractors's project schedules
um construction season and in in New
England and New
Hampshire excuse me is typically uh 12h
hour days during the summer and not not
as much during the winter obviously so
um they have that budget to keep up with
it class 59 again um see the
um some um
27 reductions there in FY 27 that
represent the um elimination of um three
full-time temporary positions in FY
27 um multif funded as well like the
other project development bureaus
um those are the core project
development bureaus uh some of the other
areas this the next uh or code 3020 on
page 822 3036 that's our spr uh research
funds spr stands for State planning and
research there is a set aside of federal
funds I forget the exact percentage but
some small percentage of the federal
funds that we get are uh supposed to go
toward planning and research um this
represents the the research portion of
of that and it's
um uh
primarily um
driven by the by the um Federal
funding that represents you know the the
the research program that we do
typically in coordination with UNH and
some of those research projects um that
go on through
that
um moving ahead into the uh M municipal
Aid categorization of our our budget um
so um on page
823 uh or 2943 that represents
apportionment A and B uh 12% of Gross
Road toll and motor vehicle fee revenues
go back to the cities and towns based on
a statutory formula um so that
apportionment uh is reflected in this or
unit
one is by population one is byad correct
yep and every every year we pay those
out quarterly and is usually true up by
the last the last quarterly payment of
of of the of the year um and it's
actually a year and it's a year and a
AER so we're making payments based on um
last year's Revenue actual actual
revenue and the estimates come the
estimates for Revenue come from safety
right
the next or code
2944 that's the planning um um element
of those spr funds that's the planning
funds um a lot of this goes towards
supporting um uh Regional planning
commissions and their
activities um um throughout there um
some some
specific uh funding changes in here
particularly class 38 technology and
software um an increase in that line
represents a a shifting in some
maintenance of ongoing um software
systems from doit Who had who had
traditionally paid for it to uh being
absorbed um by the spr
program um but a big part of that in
class 72 is the federal grants uh that
goes to support the activities of the
nine Regional planning Commissions in
the
state and it's 100% federally
funded class uh uh or code 2945 which is
the municipal Aid Federal um this or
code represents the um federal funds
that uh that that go towards um
Municipal local municipal funded or
Municipal managed projects so there are
a number of Grant programs through
Federal High uh through our federal
programs um that that cities and towns
um uh can apply for they're typically
competitive to do projects they manage
the projects um with with the federal
funds through us um and that's what this
um or code represents so it's primarily
um in um
uh grants to those uh Municipal managed
projects in class 30 class
72 um but also some of the um inter
agency transfers out of here uh go to
support some of those funds uh that go
to other um other agencies and things
like
that and the small amount of private
local funds there uh that um constitutes
the local match most of the local match
doesn't flow through the department
there are uh a limited number of
Municipal projects that the department
is managing and that reflects the local
match for those
projects sir you're anticipating a large
increase in Grants is that accurate to
say um
972 072 72 yes and just can those funds
so those are funds that we're getting
from federal government and we're
Distributing them to
municipalities we are they are for
specific projects so there are federal
funded programs that uh uh for um local
eligible projects you've applied for
that the municipalities apply for yeah
thank you y
I presume I don't my
um my supposition is it's not a um this
there's there's not a uh drastic in
increase in federal funds going to the
municipalities we we found the
municipalities are are
traditionally um
uh they have trouble getting projects to
completion and to ad advertising they
often delayed and I think it's probably
um in the FY 24 and the FY 25 adjusted
authorized it it's probably the lag of
municipalities delivering the projects
that result in those low lower numbers
than an increase in federal funds in 26
and 27
so Senator Roy can you just give me an
idea as to what kind of projects this
would fund for local would they be
Bridges roads I mean anything
dams Bridges Road so um for example in
the Federal in the federal um
reauthorization bill that came out they
had a special Bridge fund of $45 million
a year that came to New Hampshire
specifically for Bridges and in that $45
million was an allotment or an
opportunity to use about 15% of that
toward what they call off system Bridges
which would be typically Municipal
Bridges so um a a big part of these LPA
projects come from that that Federal
funding so um whatever 15% of $45
million is $9 million a year something
like that about $9 million a year go
toward um uh Municipal red lless bridges
for example you have a long list of
towns that have projects we do we do
okay there are some other uh uh programs
uh Transportation Alternatives program
um which is a competitive grant program
which is typically for uh municipalities
to uh apply for to do Trails or sidewalk
type of uh more smaller scale um
alternative transportation type of
projects so those are a couple of
examples of the um um locally managed
uh federal aid projects wonderful thank
you so uh moving on to page 826 I had
mentioned fuel distribution uh code uh
or code 4965 is the municipal fuel
portion of that um this is the fuel
purchased uh through our uh through the
state fuel system um that is purchased
by municipalities schools and Etc and
the um Revenue um offsetting that or
reference there is for is is reflected
as agency income coming from
those
um moving on into the next uh section we
get into some of the um construction
program funds so or code 3039 is the
betterment program so that represents 3
cents of the road toll that is collected
by safety so statutorily 3 cents of the
um
22.4 Cent gas tax goes to Highway
betterment uh
activities um represents uh uh about $21
million per year and um this is used for
uh you know non-federal Aid
um uh non-federal Aid construction work
on on um on State on state highways um
it supports some of the um construction
work that our districts do by by by
force account or or funding allotted to
them for small local repairs and
improvements uh a big part of this also
goes to our annual maintenance uh Paving
program to keep up with the uh Paving
needs on the
roads um and the revenue is is really
sourced by for by the Department of
Safety safy
yeah
um code 3049 is non-participating
construction uh this pays for non
participating course nonparticipating
costs associated with federal aid
projects um it's it's it's budgeted as
kind of a placeholder there are um
certain times certain activities that
come up uh and in a project that aren't
um federal aid eligible that we will
bucket them here um
the large the large number shown in FY
24 as an actual uh as an actual expense
came from uh the Conway bypass um that
was a project that was never built and
we had to pay Federal Highway back for
the um for the federal funds that we had
used to purchase property and stuff for
that project so that's that's the type
of nonparticipating work that is
reflected in this or code
um the next page 828 is the S SP 367
capital
investment that represents the uh a
dedicated fund that that represents the
4.2 Cent gas tax increase that was um
dedicated to um rural Paving and uh
Bridge work and and uh supporting The
Debt Service for the uh for the Tiffy
alone that paid for the completion of of
i93 so it's bucketed and tracked in this
in this or org unit and it is
um specifically referenced to that
dedicated portion of the gas tax
increase for this use
um uh and the biggest huh you want me to
pick some uh the biggest thing i' I'd
point out is uh you know one of the
things we're dealing with uh so for the
last and I think we covered this in the
introduction and you look at the shift
in in funds there particularly between
Debt Service uh on class 49 and uh class
400 construction repair materials so for
the last nine years we have been able to
based on the structure of the loan only
pay um interest on the loan and for the
last nine years we've been able to use
this revenue for um local Paving and
Bridge projects um beginning in FY
26 uh the um The Debt Service the we we
need to begin paying the um the
principal amount on that on that loan
hence the change um between fy2 and 26
in class
44 and the loan the loan uh will go
through uh
2034 uh before it's paid
off and I lost my train of
yeah so but that's 1.09% that's the rate
that's the rate that's the
rate there is a drop yeah there is a
drop yep so we'll be addressing that
through the through the 10-year plan
this upcoming year but uh that that that
from the state budget is a direct
reflection of of of that substantial
change this year
um the next or code under the under the
uh section of Consolidated federal aid
program is
3054 that that is uh the primary account
for our cons our our our federal aid
Highway program this is based on the uh
Federal Transportation bill um and the
10-year plan funding um that's
associated with that um this should be
budgeted in in in approach uh you know
what we anticipate for federal aid um uh
Federal Highway uh
funding
um the or codes are generally uh aligned
to support that activity and the those
activities the biggest or codes being um
you know class 46 which is for
Consultants which is a lot of our
engineering design work and hiring
Consultants class
um uh
yeah the uh the payments for tipia are
in the
8910 and you see it in class 44 yeah
page page
828 that that that class line 44 Debt
Service to other
agencies had 2 million Ion 2 million 23
million yeah so in the last like I said
nine years we've just been paying the
interest on the loan and the full
principal kicks in in
26 yes it
is yes yes it
is um Mr chair can I ask a quick
question about H Phillips um we could go
back to the Consolidated Federal
um description you just provided about
um you know primarily being a federal
aid and Highway
program does the State of New Hampshire
leave um money on the table that we
could otherwise be eligible for because
of our um you know for instance like our
our seat belt law or you know just not
participating in
in certain programs I mean is there a
chance for us to make modest adjustments
to get more Federal
funding
um no not really we we take great pride
that we that we I don't think there's
been a year since I've worked at the
department for 37 years that we haven't
fully obligated all of our available
federal funds every year so the seat
belt y Law you reference I know there is
certifications that that we do um
despite not having a seat belt law uh
there is data on voluntary usage that
that I know we do
um um certify every year so that we
aren't penalized for for federal funds
for things like that so the one area uh
that that we don't tend to compete as
well for has been some of the recent
discretionary grants um opportunities
but um we have got we have got some like
the like the um the grant to do the um
the seaw walls in in Northampton and Rye
but um uh that is an
area uh but again it's highly
competitive as well to those
discretionary grants of additional
federal funds so there are also
penalties if we don't meet Our
obligation limit so we are highly
motivated to meet them
sure um moving ahead uh or code
88683 that's the Garvey Debt Service
um happy to happy to show here that uh
our our last payment is due on 9125 and
um we will have paid off that that
Garvey debt so for some of you that
don't know Garvey Debt Service
represents another form of financing uh
that we had done to um support the i93
Reconstruction project um it involves
pledging um pledging future Federal
Federal Aid Revenue um to to support a
uh to support a loan um to build the
project
so thank you so basically when I'm
looking at the combined impact of the
8910 Deb service where the principal
kicks in in 26 and the Garvey where the
principal ends in 26 we're basically
getting one big hump in 26 and then more
or less we're just getting a $4 million
net increase so the pain for
8910 kind of gets matched and offset by
the joy of finishing Garvey you're
exactly right the loan the tifia loan
was structured primarily to not
primarily but with with the goal of
having a
relatively um consistent Debt Service so
as the as the as the Garvey Debt Service
declined the the Tipp Debt Service thank
personally I prefer declining Debt
Service but I'll settle for the and the
flattish thing so I appreciate it thank
you
um so we're almost done thank you all
for your patience hopefully this is
helpful when you getting your questions
answer we're on the last uh org unit on
page 831 which Begins the uh Turnpike
division the turnpike division is is
organized a a
little um I don't know complicated
a little differently yeah um but um
again getting back this is all primarily
Turnpike funds supported by the turnpike
uh toll toll Revenue so it's divided up
into um uh you know a number of
different uh or organizational units the
first one being 722 which is the
administration and support um this is uh
you know all things with the overall
organization and oversight of the of the
uh of the turnpike
system um I think the only things that
are that need a little bit of clarity is
uh class
29 is is where the billing for Direct
Services that are provided by Highway
design I mean uh Highway
funded units goes so places like
Mechanical Services and Bridge
maintenance and traffic and tismo and
those kind of things those go those
expenses are shown in 29 and then in
class 40 um those are the indirect costs
uh where the indirect costs are going so
we saw indirect cost revenues on the
other side and here's the expense side
of
things trying that may be a some people
have asked that question and as we look
at some of the capital needs there may
be some discussion of that coming up but
uh pardon me uh perhaps in future years
as well to continue that discussion yeah
certainly
um yep so I'm the the the individual
class lines there there are uh a number
of specific items in in in those um
administrative lines that are um that
are represented but um I don't know um
drastic changes
um within that support um the next line
the next order code on 83 page 833 is
7025 which is the renewal and
replacement um this represents um work
on the turnpike system needed to keep it
in a state of of good repair um it's
based on the turnpike Capital plan um it
represents um primarily the construction
project
uh the paving program The Bridge
Rehabilitation uh things that are just
um um keeping the turnpike system assets
and good repair it does not reflect uh
investment in new capacity or or capital
investment type of projects um and that
level of investment is is what is uh
deemed necessary by by various studies
to um keep up with the with the with the
needs the maintenance needs needs on the
on the TR bike system I would note uh
you know one increase in in um FY 26 in
class 400 construction repairing
materials that represents you know
specifically a a prod do touch-up
painting on the um on the um high level
bridge between uh the I95 pascatore
river bridge between um New Hampshire
and
Maine um Pap fish $10 million worth of
paint yeah it's a big bridge I know it's
a big bridge just a bit uh taken back
but again I trust you guys that you uh
calculated it correctly but still holy
mother of God it is it is a big project
there are there are like I said some
specific projects I again that that
Flags mostly it's a pretty even even
type of program but that uh you
know that's a type of project we don't
we don't do every year Paving we we pave
certain sections of the turnpike every
every year so it's a relatively
consistent investment those those
one-offs are those on those specialty
type of projects that that prop up do do
reflect in a little bit of a spike and
I'm assuming the painting is needed for
maintenance reasons not for aesthetic
purposes exactly yeah yeah thank you no
we call the I we've I mean the I95
Bridge we call it a forever Bridge
because it you know we we need to
continue to preserve and maintain it cuz
uh the cost of replacing that bridge or
building a new one would be you know uh
substantial so and we pay the full cost
or do Maine involved as
well um Maine would typically be in
involved don't show up in there yet
their
revenues I believe it may depend on
whether
um we're doing the project or they've
they're they're doing the project so we
may not have M main funds coming to us
as as as part of this um un unlike
unlike the like the liftbridge
operations you know we New Hampshire do
that and and but it but it's split 5050
for this work this is probably just New
Hampshire's share of that work but
whatever contract that that gets
executed will have main share in it as
well it may not flow through our budget
so
yeah
yeah yeah so um did you have a
question yes maam D Roy total curiosity
the turnpikes that we have are any of
those turnpikes privately owned the
roads themselves that we no no they're
not so we bought
everything yes okay yes
right they might I don't know how that
happens but um so we can go through the
rest of these relatively quickly uh
again it's structured a little awkward
because uh each each separate Turnpike
the central Turnpike the blue star
Turnpike the Spalding Turnpike all have
separate funding lines for operation and
maintenance so uh org 7026 is a central
operations represented
there the cost for that code 727 is the
uh you know is the central maintenance
that's the maintenance on the central uh
New Hampshire Turnpike on page
um oh yeah go ahead Daniel so one of the
things I want to point out is even
though on the on the highway side we
can't fund the retention incentive and
the winter maintenance piece but on the
turnpike side those items are funded so
the retention incentive is is funded in
the turnpike side as is as our increases
in salt sand and rented
equipments yes there is some transfers
for yeah yes repres papich quick
question if I may thank you um I'm
looking at the ratio between the wages
in line 10 and the benefits in line 60
and it's almost a 3 to2 between wages
and benefits is that a bit higher than
usual I'm just curious if that's the
normal ratio because obviously benefits
are expensive especially when you talk
about providing health insurance to
somebody who doesn't have very high
wages that tends to bring that rati show
up so just any thoughts on that so so
it's at least equivalent so an hour of
labor would have at least an hour of
benefit associated with it thank
you depends of course how much they're
making but in general so if I may just
to remind everybody all of the positions
the permanent classified positions are
funded at either the existing positions
salary and benefit package or if it's a
vacant position the starting salary and
I believe a two-person plan is assumed
for the uh HMO benefits so all of those
are driven by uh backup working rates
for the um salary tables and the uh
benefits
um guess we can go through these one one
by one on page 835 72 code 727 is
Central Central maintenance um and
that's a cost to maintain that and as U
um uh Danielle pointed out we do have
the um winter maintenance and some of
the other um
uh materials and stuff budgeted there um
we do have some for example
um you know additional costs reflected
in those budgets particularly class line
400 um we're we're we're budgeting for
um for uh a bridge washing contract
similarly on on on the turnpike
system and um you know some of the other
contracts for op operational Services uh
you see some increases there um some of
that is graffiti removal this is class
103 um as well as some of the uh cleanup
costs that we um encounter with u um
homeless encampments within the r of
way um and if you look at
um the agency income there is a a line
there for uh 09 that represents the
patrol vehicle sponsorship so the uh
service Patrol vehicle that that we have
an agreement with I think it's Geico
they provide uh a about 50% of that
operating cost as part of the
sponsorship
um on the vehicle
itself
um page 836 is the Eastern New Hampshire
blue star operations that's org
7031 um there are some changes in class
10 which represents some shifting around
of uh Staffing from from the do and
Rochester toll plazas uh at the end of
last year um over in Rochester Capital
project went into to eliminate those
tolls plazas make it all electronic
tolling so some of those Personnel were
were shifted down to um to um to Hampton
for example and those costs are
reflected in class
10 um but that's still part of the New
Hampshire turn blue star operation
because I don't see any changes in the
numbers of people you'll see it in the
Rochester Rochester in in the Spalding
Turn
Pike
yeah so on page 838 if you look at 7
7036 the Eastern New Hampshire ter
spaling turn bike operations you'll see
like class 10 that reduction of of some
of those positions that are shifted and
you see the shifting of positions
occurred in
25 um on page 837 is the Eastern New
Hampshire Turnpike uh Blue Star
Maintenance um that's the maintenance of
I95 uh we just talked on 838 about the
Hampshire Turnpike Spalding Turnpike
operations and Spalding Turn Pike
maintenance um again just the cost of uh
operating and maintaining those
facilities and see the position changes
there
yeah
um and then on page 839 um or code
77050 that represents the um the toll
collection organization called the cost
of doing business the to cost of um um
uh you know operating the easy path
system and the toll collection
um um activities there
um again that those are the
general kind of dramatic we contracts
increased
102 cubic y yep okay y that just is what
it is that's the back office system that
handles all of the Easy Pass
transactions
and that just by contract it's going up
in it's by contract next budget
yes uh what do you mean going to New
Jersey it's No Easy Pass is an inter
Agency Group Cupic is a is a is is the
vendor that that operates our back
office system they they uh they operate
all of the
uh collection the customer service
center and things like like that the
billing
yeah yeah right and we have agreements
with them to collect in those
States the one the one U item that I
would point out to for example class 46
um you see an increase from 26 27 from
$50,000 to $800,000 that
represents um a new RFP for the back
office so just we're getting toward the
end of of of our present vendors uh
contract I think in 28 or 29 so we do
have some money budgeted there to begin
an RFP process to look at um to to look
at uh a new vendor um Rob on papovich
thank you um just to come back to line
102 for a moment I hear you say that
it's a contract increase
but that is a massive increase in a
contract could you help us understand a
little bit more as why such a steep
increase has been built in the
contract cuz you know we are talking 6
million more or less I mean what's a few
million between friends you
know yeah I I'll have to look I know we
had just recently um
um we did we did the contract extension
on on that on that option um I I do you
know Dave I think the I think the
adjusted authorized or even the actual
expenditures are probably somewhat low
low cuz I know that the contracts was
around the $21 million a year and that
reflected uh um additional accounts
additional
um um cost of living and higher
operating costs but yeah and a a small
amount of that or a portion of that is
related to going to all electronic
tolling um on the Spalding turnpike so
where we eliminated the toll booths so
now
all of our toll collection is through
this system so it increases the number
of letters that they have to send out to
people who don't have Easy Pass
transponders and so forth thank you
um knowing that one of those letters
tends to ask for a lot of money are we
seeing a you know in matching increase
in expected revenues from all those
people who pay more I mean I know that
you have a brief period of time when you
can pay your toll without a Hefty fee
but after that it gets pretty expensive
pretty quickly
so right so most of the revenue is
predicated on the total amount which
hasn't been increased in in a number of
years postage has continued to increase
labor has continued to increase all of
those are required to um send out bills
in the mail and collect and process and
provide that customer service understood
and if I may ask about a slightly
different line I was just looking at
line 020 the current
expenses while we are not talking about
the same amount of money it's still a
bit of a difference between the actuals
in 24 and the budgeted amount I just
wanted to understand whether that would
be you know a onetime blip or is it just
the account has a bit of a room in it a
lot of this is uh credit card processing
fees MH that we pay and because there's
increases in Easy Pass usage and
transponder usage you're going to see
more of that thank you so it's an
estimate it's an estimate of that
increas course I appreciate it thank you
I'm good and if I may one more thing we
are also in the process of converting
Bedford to all electronic tolling so
that will impact these future costs as
well and also provide some savings on
the operations of the U bedf to thank
you trigger the toll increase and I
guess that has to be done by the
legislature pardon
me will trigger the toll increase
usually it was the amount of funds that
were in Surplus and so on and we'd look
at it every few years it's been quite a
while since we increased the toll and
obviously the costs will keep going up
on all this stuff
yeah
uh what would trigger a toll increase uh
well one one one thing I know to the the
toll rates are are governed by governor
and councel um the the the discounts are
overseen by the registrat because years
ago we said you know I remember could be
15 years ago we said why haven't you
increased the tolls and executive
Council said oh we wouldn't get
elected so we had to take it away from
them and do it same as we did with the
court as far as I know in statute I
think that the toll rate is still is
still governed by uh governor and
Council legislature has oversight over
any any discounts or physical locations
of the tolling locations and and the and
the toll plazas at the time we increased
it it was okay you can't the Surplus has
got to be a certain amount in the fund
and it's reducing to this and so you got
to go back up and incre and I know it
would be very expensive because
of signage and excuse me all the
electronic stuff that would have to be
redone yeah well we definitely are
seeing increases in costs um on the
turnpike side there is an order a
pecking order on on expenses and that is
debt Services first operations is next
re uh renewal and replacement is next
leaving Capital last and so some of the
things that we are seeing are is the
pushing of capital projects out so
that's how you know that you're not
quite there well I mean it's it's
flexible we can increase the toll it's
probably going to be a few million bucks
to have a toll increase but if you bring
in another 20 30 million you have to do
it if that's what the costs are doing
and I see all these costs keep going up
and up and
up and we are we are having those
conversations right there'll be some
discussions with the 10e plan next year
particularly some of those capital
projects keep getting pushed out I
remember at one point we took it away
from the executive councel because they
were dragging their feet and and the
Turnpike was not meeting the requirement
to have the a certain amount of surplus
so we went up
yeah 2009 was the last uh that's my
total increase yeah
yeah repres
Roy how many years to pay off this
investment that we have on all the
electronic F
uh TOS in other words we had the other
ones we were just thrown our money in
there
how much did it cost us and what was the
anticipated uh Break Even point for for
this good question we're right at uh uh
or code 77499 on page 840 which
represents the turnpike Debt Service so
uh these are the current Debt Service uh
payments for the um for the bonds that
are that are outstanding so their total
outstanding debt is about
$184,000 million 1884 million that was a
good deal that would be nice yeah
um and those were three bond series uh
first one being in
2009 uh it was refinanced in
2019 uh and there was a refunding series
in
2022 so we are not close to paying those
off it'll be in the thir in the in the
2030s OR
2040 it's out there but I can get you I
had the I had those uh Bond schedules
with me but I don't think I brought them
so I can I can get you a better answer a
closer
answer and then um I guess we can cover
we can finish up real real quick 841 is
um sorry where were we on so that was
the turnpike debt service
749 74.99 on page
um on page 841 is uh uh code 7500 with
which is the
um uh blue star Memorial
umik do you know what that is
for
bridge oh that's for the high level
bridge for the that must be the
maintenance of the high level Bridge
yeah and compesi
um I'll have to check a little bit more
um talking about 7500 yep
7500 I think it's a placeholder I think
it's a placeholder
too
um so most of these last few accounts
are are are are are
um various
um limited activities on the turnpike
system so
7507 uh that those those represent the
Capital Improvements that that are
budgeted along the central turnpike so
yes
yeah so I I told you it was a little
awkward the way things were organized
but uh
755 represents the
um you know primarily the capital
expenditures and work that's going on in
the central New Hampshire
Turnpike 751 on page 842 is um
represents the toll collection equipment
um one of the big costs there
particularly um is the conversion of
Bedford AET going forward
um on page
um I think these are mainly placeholder
accounts there was a project at one
point to consider a new exit 10 that's
7512 that um I I don't think is uh
anything is happening with
that um 7514 again represents the
Capital Improvements on the spaling
turnpike most of those in Rochester to
area have been
completed um so some placeholder amounts
there
um P quick question on the spoing
obviously seeing how we are uh finishing
that work and taking a break yeah
ballpark uh how much of a break do you
think that will be until spoing will
need uh more work just trying to
understand like the light the the
cyclical nature of the
projects so I know on on previous uh uh
so we've done I give my my sense you
know on the on the Spalding turnike
we've taken care of the Rochester and
there's been a lot of investment and and
and um redoing of the of the turnpike
system around around Rochester over the
last past eight or nine years we've just
rebuilt the Spalding Turnpike between
Newington and Dover and the new bridges
over the little Bay there's a section
there um
uh from from north of dova Point Road to
to say um where the um all electronic
tolling project is in in
Rochester um that
that there are no Capital plans but I
would say it needs to be studied and and
looked at there's a lot of growth in the
Sea Coast Area and I know that those um
interchanges are are you know kind of
outdated outdated uh geometry from the
from the
from the 1950s so thank you this helps
yeah but there isn't I mean that that is
one of those uh future needs uh some
sort of study and and assessment and and
and take it from there yeah represent D
Roy do you have any idea when um 16 is
going to be taken care of going up
towards
Conway from Rochester up because that's
obviously it's such a
dangerous there have been a whole there
have been series of projects uh along
there no expansion planned other than
just rebuild rebuilding and and
reconstruction so we just did uh project
last year um several years uh from like
Route 28 up past Green Mountain
Furniture we just did another project uh
completed this year um up over the hill
by by Shaw Road and stuff there that
that was more of a a reconstruction of
the
existing uh infrastructure but no
planned widening I know in the Tenya
plan we have other projects planned to
look at Route 16 between um alany
Madison and into and into Conway um but
again more um uh reconstruction of the
existing facility maybe addressing some
of the safety issues some of the
intersection areas consistent shoulder
width but uh no wholesale um expansion
or anything planned okay thank you
um and then finally on on page 844 it's
a transponder inventory fund um this is
just a kind of resolve revolving uh fund
from from the revenue to buy and sell uh
the easy paath
transponders um we've lowered it a
little uh in the future years uh due to
uh decrease in in transponder sales um
that was a
I I think we've we've got something like
a 75 or 78% Market penetration so um the
growth is is just with whatever
population growth seems to be versus a
whole lot of new um Easy Pass customers
so um and the
final or is uh uh on page 845 817
compensation
benefits and again those are similar to
the other other um Highway funded ones
those are
um um workers comp and retirement
pension benefit Health Plans provided by
Das for the turnpike employees
so that brings us to the end of our
budget well done with your
timing um we have we have hb2 items as
well though do you have do you have few
minutes to go through those yeah
absolutely so we have three proposed Law
changes I didn't make enough
copies
um that we missed in the
submission I think get
a about this one
first well I started talking about this
so we might as well talk about this so
so we have three three proposed Law
changes um that we that we're trying to
put through um I'm going to let
commissioner talk about this one because
I don't know
it yeah I think these were the when we
submitted the budget there were some um
there were some uh recommended changes
that that we we neglected to uh fully um
convey through uh Department of
administrative services so these were
typically things that would be
considered in hb2 uh in the trailer bill
um um th this this one these are
typically statute real rule changes that
are um that are um you know either
housekeeping or other thing things like
like like that so
um the um additional statute here is a
is a
claraty um relative to you know work
that uh that is being done you know
within the highway within the state
right of way or state owned railroad
Corridor
um
yeah you want to check you got that okay
that was sh's proposal yeah I was trying
to read it as we talk I'll talk about
mine though
yeah thank you so um the requested
change to RSA
23619 obstructing water penalty is to
add in anywhere it had um a highway at
or state owned railroad Corridor we
consider the railroad coordinators to be
longitudinal and linear Transportation
corridors just like the roadway side of
the house would consider our highways um
we have linear butters on both sides um
from time to time they'll they'll change
and obstruct the flow of water that
impacts the railroad Corridor just like
it could a roadway so we see scouring
out we see dams being built we see our
drainage being being impacted so um for
the for the Department for the railroad
side of the house and for our ownership
of um approximately 450 miles of
railroad quds we're looking for the same
treatment under statute that the highway
um side has so that we can continue to
keep our infrastructure uh in a cost-
effective Manner well-maintained and so
we don't have any expensive um
Investments of of Maintenance in the
future
uh the second
item is an efficiency uh a rule
change So currently the um the division
of finance currently assigns manages and
releases
encumbrances and we do quite I'm sorry
did you Skip One or was she talking
about two she was talking about the
first one you on are you on RSA 941 now
no the second one there's a second one
on that page yeah sorry I'm sorry I
don't know
oops honestly I'm not sure how it's
related to you because it seems to be
lottery or whatever but I'm just trying
just a suggestion what we've encountered
between the classified and unclassified
positions is has been some compression
so as some of the um some of the
um some of the reclassification and and
pay raises and things that have gone
gone gone gone forward we we found
compression at those uh higher levels
between um you know some senior
Administration senior Bureau
administrators and in our um
unclassified um directive position so
statute right now requires I think a
$1,000 um pay differential between an
unclassified position and any one they
supervise um we've run into cases where
that's um had to continually be been
been redone uh so so we are we're
recommending or suggesting um a a
different um um uh value uh to to
promote that separation Alexis do you
want to add to that or sure um so um we
have five directors so these are the
unclassified positions in the salary set
um for um with the increases uh with the
um classification
changes um some of the administrator
positions that report directly to the
directors um just in uh base wages alone
are are making more than them um So
currently like the commissioner said
it's at $1,000 difference there must be
a $1,000 difference um so uh as an
example we we have a director um who is
significantly lower um than her uh
highest paid classified report so every
time that person gets an increment we
have to go to governor and councel again
and ask for the difference to be added
to that person's salary um so it's it's
every time the classified employees get
an increase it it continues to compress
that Gap and cause more uh GNC
attendance I distinctly remember once
upon a time in my uh many careers uh
having been told that uh if I want to
switch from my job as a trainer to a
manager I would have to take a pay cut
cuz managers were paid less I'm just
trying to understand why we have the
presumption that a manager has to make
more than anybody that reports to them
especially with certain specialized
positions that are very hard to find I I
want to show a lot of respect to the
administrators but sometimes you just
got to pay the techie that does the job
more cuz you just don't have enough of
them so I'm just trying to understand
where that is coming from I understand
that's the current law and right now it
creates administrative pain for you
because you got to keep making
adjustments M but is the Department's
position that that you know those wage
differentials have to be there when
people report on a chain or is it just
your need to comply with existing law
that just is a something you got to
respect I think it's the need to comply
to the existing law there's also um you
know some some incentive and benefit to
incentivize and and uh encourage people
to step up into those higher levels of
of responsibility two that we depend on
there's almost a a disincentive for for
for somebody to um Step Up into a
director's position um because of that
compression I get that and now if we
change the differential from the current
statutory I understand it's 1,000 you're
looking to change it to five I'm not
clear how that would decrease the number
of trips because still you have a larger
Gap but every time the bottom comes up
you'll have to move the top so right so
for um one position in particular um in
our agency one of the director positions
it needs to go through an unclassified
reclass um because I I do believe it's
inappropriately uh lowly uh classified
so we do need to go through that process
um with um in this current uh in the spe
specific situations we have the um both
of the division directors and the
employees of their direct reports have
been with us for a very long so they are
both maxed
out just say it bluntly at where they
can go so um anytime that now there's a
CBA increase it's going to result in
more so we've kind of met the cap of
going back and forth um but anytime now
that there's an increase across the
board through collective bargaining or
anything like that is the only time
where that we would have to go back um
and I believe if we had the 5,000 limit
versus the 1,000 limit it would really
um eliminate a lot of back and forth in
most of these situations because we're
we're literally talking about a 4%
increase every time so $1,000 to the
next step is now it has to be $1,000 but
it's we're only asking for 700 so every
time you're asking for a different
amount of money um to governor and
Council based on what the two people are
making so it's a suggestion of something
that that that we had uh put forward but
we recognize that it has you know it is
it is it is a it is
a directly attributed to some issues
that that we are having but uh certainly
recognize that this has a
bigger uh SP of impact
um
but also
CH no I don't think so just changes the
parameters the differential
yeah
yeah and you're saying the detriment
would be if we just repealed it that
what some people wouldn't want to become
a director
I I think part of the det detriment of
of of of
um having that that thousand Gap and and
where we have some Bureau administrators
really really um kind of bumping up to
that un unclassified level it's a
disincentive for for people to uh
consider taking on those higher
positions of responsibility I mean it's
not unusual in the private sector to
have people reporting to people that
make less than them sure or even in
government think about some of the
things we saw over the past four years
with the highest paid employees making
more than the president by a lot sure
yeah and some changes have been made in
in the past few years recently to um try
to address the disincentive of taking an
unclassified position um because at at
our agency anyway I've never been at
another agency um that administrator who
is making more than the director is
being asked to take that director role
so they are being asked to take a
decrease they're no longer earning leave
um so uh one of the changes recently
made was you previously you had to cash
out your leave now you get to take it
with you it goes into a grandfathered
bank and then you earn I believe it's
four days of leave per year to then cash
out when you retire um so they are and I
believe the $11,000 thing was put in
there as well um but but if you're
asking somebody who makes 120 to now
take a position that only makes
98 and not earn any leave towards their
cash out at retirement I guess I'm
confused as to why when you're asking
somebody to take on a higher role you
couldn't at that point pay pay them more
in statute we paid what we
paid we paid what we're paid the
directors don't have when you go to a
classified from unclassified it's not
you're not a different pay scale so
there's an unclassified wage schedule
and we're paid by Statute I believe um
so uh some of those uh currently do are
significantly lower than what the
classified employees who are played by
the hour make at the end of the
year is it just hitting your department
oh no this is probably across the board
but I'm not at another agency so I I
don't know um you there is a list of
positions um and we can go by title to
just determine if something is a like
position and where it is on that salary
schedule okay I I think the right
solution is if it's really a problem
that you would change the pay scales of
the so you could give the person a raise
whatever not not play a game with this
this is just I don't understand this I
guess I need to understand maybe give me
some more realistic examples some actual
examples I can understand what's going
on here and where the change should
really be made it it just doesn't seem
like the right way to make it
representative so I understand what
you're saying I don't understand the
mechanism
okay so the state government and federal
government are very
different yeah we can provide some
additional information but it's it's
just a suggestion or something that that
we observed and it was a recommendation
we would uh like like to make but it's
just that a recommendation so you want
to get to the last one have two more
thank you
Alexis So currently so this is really to
to put something that's been a practice
for 20 years or more um on paper because
I can't find where the agreement is for
this because it I've only been here 10
years so um So currently the the
division of finance manages all of the
incumbrances for do it manages all the
incumbrances there's about 735 items um
we also manage all the task orders
within those there's about 500 items um
we have staff that that have been doing
this we have rules that that have been
applied to this for as long as I can
find somebody who has
history um but it is not in writing
anywhere and so the suggestion that I
received was to come and have it added
to law so what I'm asking for is to have
the authority to encumber at do to
encumber and unencumber funds for
Approved expenditures task fors and
items approved um once they're approved
at GNC which is what we're current
currently
doing and then the set the next item is
um Shelly would you like to talk about
the
park last
one oh
yeah so as the commissioner said we um
the department owns
and manages many Park and Ride Lots we
just have the the two that went through
the public private partnership but other
than that our district forces or our
contracted facility operators are
responsible um for the park and ride
facilities we've seen uh a lot of
abandoned vehicles being left at Park
and Ride locations including um you know
campers and and things that are really
expensive um to have to deal with we've
seen co- companies who have actually
brought and left them at the direction
of the the purported owner and and dump
them at Park and Ride lots and right now
it's incumbent upon the department to
take from our limited resources
Financial Resources to pay for this so
we're we're looking for this change um
so that the cost of the removal of the
Campers or Vehicles would be on the toe
toe company if they're bringing them and
dumping them and and putting them there
essentially um it's it's upwards of
about
$5,000 in some cases for for campers to
be removed from Park and Ride Lots so
the last item for hb2 was in the
presentation on the last page and it was
to add
Revenue um it it was to add revenue for
the P3 uh income that we're receiving
that is not currently in the budget so
there are two sources of revenue
sustainment fund revenue and Rental
income Revenue we'd like to be able to
budget some of that um in this budget
and also need two dedicated funds
because the funds are restricted uh by
use uh the rental income is restricted
because it was previously purchased with
federal funds so there's a federal
agreement that's tied to this on what we
can use the funding
for the sustainment fund is restricted
to maintenance of the facilities only I
believe yes so I'm looking for two
dedicated funds to be able to put that
in
and you're saying that both those
dedicated funds are required by federal
agreements I would say that one of them
is is required by federal by based on
the federal uh agreement that was made
because the property was purchased with
federal funds the second one is tied to
the agreement itself that says that the
the the use of the funds can only be for
a certain purpose and shell can explain
and I would say it's this is probably
more of an issue with with you know
the the you know the state budget
structure so you know if if if we didn't
have these
dedicated uh funds to keep these
separate to maintain this facility and
for the contract requirements These
funds would go to the to the highway
fund right or unct general fund or go to
the general fund and and just be part of
everything so just ask we did a similar
this is we structured this agreement
very similar to how we did the uh um uh
the the rest areas in hookit uh that's a
long-term uh land lease for for that the
difference is with with the turnpike
system being being a an Enterprise fund
we have control within the turnpike
system of establishing these dedicated
funds to keep the um to keep the funds
in the venue that come in associated
with that you know going just toward
that facility we don't have a similar
mechanism in the broader state
government financial system I was just
asking because we are trying to decrease
complexity a little and this adds
complexity so I know I hear you I had I
had a conversation with treasury about
this um because the agreement called for
putting the funds in a separate bank
account or a separate fund and earning
interest and that's not really necessary
they can they can still use pooled funds
and get the advantage of the pulled
funds like they do now they would just
need to book um interest on them on a
quarterly basis right so they've agreed
that that's the way that they would
approve that what who's requiring
this so um Deputy Commissioner Brier
spoke earlier about the the P3 project
uh because the property that the dot
owns for do and uh the Portsmouth
portion were bought with Federal Highway
funds in order for the Department to do
a P3 contract and solicitation the
department entered into agreement with
the Federal Highway Administration
headquarters it's the the first one that
we're aware of in in the country to be
able to do um something that's Revenue
generating on federal property so we
entered into an early development
agreement that allowed for concessions
and charge for parking so as part of
that Revenue generation on federally
purchased property uh Federal Highway
came up with restricted uses of the
revenue uh to be Transit supportive
which was the original investment in the
property was to support shared ride use
activity so they've restricted what we
can spend that revenue on so that is the
one that is restricted by um Federal
requirements and then the facility
sustainment fund much like at the hooks
at rest areas we were requiring the
contractor to pay into an account so
should they not step up under the
obligations of their contract and make
um essentially safety improvements or uh
to the facilities that we own then we
will have a fund on which we can draw
and we can invest the funds that they've
paid in to make our facilities um whole
and safe for public use so there's no
requirement in that latter case the
that's a contractual requirement oh
contractual a contract that went through
the contract went through governor and
Council for the facility sustainment
fund and because it's dedicated Revenue
coming from that contract to be invested
in those facilities who are the parties
to the contract the parties of the
contract are the department
transportation and C&J what is C&J and
Portsmith uh bus Prov so jalbert leasing
doing business as C&J Bus so the bus
line is demanding that you no the bus
line is paying into the facility
sustainment fund as our 30-year Lessie
of the property the money comes in and
the department and the peas Development
Authority in the case of um Portsmith
have control of those funds so if there
are any safety concerns that need to be
addressed that C&J does not step up to
do we take those revenues that were paid
into this account and we can hire a
contractor to go make those improvements
so this is just the one that's related
to the Port Port of Development
Authority not the other one which is not
involving that no Dover has the same
requirement it's just in the case of the
there's two facility sustainment funds
one for do that the department has full
control over and there's a facility
sustainment fund for Portsmith that both
PDA and the department have joint one
first the do one that's already in place
the contract was approved by governor
and Council in December no no I mean the
the separate fund is already in place
dedicated fund that's what we're try
that's what we're trying to establish
asking with three things
here be one facility sustainment fund
but we could we would have separate
accounting to know how much was
dedicated to do and how much was
dedicated to stick with the do one who
are the parties of the contract the
parties of the contract for do are the
state with the Department of
Transportation being the contract
manager in jalbert leasing doing
business as C&J Bus okay so the bus
company demanded this part of the
contract negotiation when we went out to
RFP and negotiated the contract was to
use a similar model that we had used for
the hooks at rest area so that the state
as the underlying fee simple owner would
have access to funds should our lesie
not I understand what they put by
understand is why the state entered into
these kinds of
agreements we issued an RFP we we we
solicited this this this input we put
together the the contract to enter into
this uh agreement right so I'm just
trying to understand why the state is
entering is putting itself in these
positions of requiring these dedicated
funds because we want to protect the we
want to protect the the underlying State
asset so these are these are p3s we
aren't selling these outright uh uh to
to to the uh to the vendor the state is
retaining Pro ownership as part of this
public private partnership we're working
with with with the vendor on a long-term
lease so having these maintenance um uh
agreements protects the underlying State
Property these are owned by the state
correct at least this particular one is
y okay yeah the state owns it yes the
state backs it why need a dedicated fund
I mean this all these special dedicated
funds are not necessary for the next 35
years we are putting the main and
operation of this facility in the hands
of a third party so protect so protect
so to protect the state's interest we're
requiring them to pay into this fund all
right so it's our requirement it's not
cnjs it's our requirement as part of the
contract to uh protect the to protect
the state uh property I get all that I
just don't understand why the dedicated
fund that's the only piece I'm missing
because it's it's restricted revenue for
a purpose I understand what I understand
what these funds are they're not good
fiscal management basically we don't
really need to have a thousand as we
have literally probably a thousand
dedicated funds and we don't I don't
believe we have another Avenue besides
this dedicated fund to to Full Faith and
Credit of the State of New
Hampshire we don't have I I we can dig
into it a little bit more and provide a
better explanation than than we're
providing here but I think the the
mechanism of collecting and retaining
These funds to protect the the state
interest um I guess you're right you're
you're not protecting the state interest
We believe We Are We believe we're we're
protecting the the interest in this
facility rather than having all these
having these maintenance funds go to the
General Highway fund for appropriation
to everyone and at some point in the
future if that default on the contract
happens having the the whole state or or
general fund be responsible for it we
want to set up this this fund to protect
just this facility and it holds the
operator
accountable
correct yes
yeah sustainment account correct that's
correct it's a requirement it's a
requirement as part of the contract that
we put on them to pay into this
account no no no I think they again
intend to be good partners there's a a
cap on the maximum that will be paid in
over time will we review that annually
we do a facility assessment so I think
they understood that that was part of
the um price of doing business with the
state knowing that there was some risk
involved and this being the first time
that we're doing this in the realm of
public
transportation well we can provide a
better briefing I I can I can see it
it's out late in the morning and I I
know you're you sound frustrated
representative and I don't want to uh we
we need to do a better job explaining it
and if there was a uh a a mechanism that
that we have um W without going this
route or establishing a dedicated fund
um that that that would be preferable to
us as well too and I I tried that but
that there are no other avenues to
restrict the revenue I was told okay
well we can agreed the question is that
seems to be there's no need to restrict
the revenue
if somebody can explain to me why then
but we don't don't do it now yeah
certainly that's a good question that
we'll get back
to El said
everybody I really appreciate the
Committees time and attention here
you've been very uh thank no thank you
very much it's been fantastic I
apologize for the this misunderstanding
of the end here which I still
misunderstand but the presentation's
been great okay and you've been really
good with the time I you got a lot in in
very little time so thank you very much
thank you thank you and with that I'll
close the hearing
um at
1227 at 1227 we back at 1 and we'll be
back at 1 and did
you oh thank you yeah thank
you
e
e e
the finance division 2 meeting and this
afternoon we have the department of
safety with us and before we get going
um I'm reminded that um we kind of went
kind of slowly this morning and this one
apparently is even longer uh more so
more more time so if we look at a lot of
if we see federal funds we maybe should
kind of move quickly past those um
accounts and if we get to accounts that
have relatively small amounts maybe we
could kind of move past those accounts
and just try to keep things moving
because um they got a lot to get through
and hopefully we will all get through it
so with that um I will welcome our
guests from the Department of Safety and
ask that you introduce yourselves and uh
start right on in
good afternoon I'm Amy Newbury I'm the
director of administration at the
department of safety and with me today
is commissioner Quinn and Melanie carer
Melanie is the deputy director of
administration at the department of
safety so I first wanted to start today
with just going over what's in your
pocket while I'm not going to go through
all of this I just wanted to explain
what's in front of you so the first um
the PowerPoint um the the first item is
the PowerPoint now you have seen a lot
of this before so I just wanted to point
out some of the changes that are in here
um so if I flagged a couple of pages
that I'm going to ask you to kindly look
at the first one is page nine of the
PowerPoint so each of our seven
divisions have a page um where their
overall budget um is in this PowerPoint
and we have updated the colors in here
as well as a recommend ation from
representative Pap papovich um so
hopefully it's easier for you to see um
this is based on the governor's targets
um and we have met those
targets so the um and then of course in
here um I didn't change any of the if
you want to look at the Department's org
charts the division org charts the
mission and vision and the the um you
know what it is that we do all of that
in here those are on change from the
first presentation now the second flag
in here is on page 12 and that um we're
going to talk a lot about today which um
the commissioner will talk about in a
bit and that is the um Granite Shield
Northern shield and Northern border
Alliance I think that it's um while it's
in the budget book and we'll go through
it I think this slide will help uh
provide more context to these programs
and Define them a little bit differently
so I wanted just to put it in here for
um for some guidance later so that's the
PowerPoint okay you're
good so the second G although it's very
small we can certainly follow up with
this electronically um this is a list of
funded vacant positions
um this is a a working document if you
will so have another paper copy that
Micky I don't think I have the
electronic version this is attached to
the
PowerPoint I don't that online oh there
is a PowerPoint there by that's for
chairman one have mine for no no it's
okay order
yeah I'm an electronic person that's you
you're going to send out a I will
forward this I will send it
electronically um so this is this
document is a um this is everchanging if
you will so this is only a moment in
time we are still advertising we are
still filling positions so I know that
um for example we have on this list um
we are filling we filled nine Trooper
positions recently um and we are still
advertising and filling positions so
this is again just a moment in time so
we can keep this updated if you'd like
we rewind just a moment of course these
are yeah your these are funded positions
and you're indicating whether or not
they're filled or
not these are currently funded vacant
positions these are all the vacancies at
the time we pulled the report yes and
their funding source is in here as
well so just to be clear when you do
send this to me please send me an Excel
spreadsheet don't send me a PDF
okay repres Roy how many positions is it
h do you know the count on
this oh I don't want you to have to
count it if you don't know it off the
top of your
head
um I don't have the
count and what if I may what percentage
um are the vacancies compared to you
know your
you're both
incredible sorry I thought you were
listening to what this is fantastic yeah
yes thank you
Ju Just So the Committees where that
Excel file is coming to you via email
now so you're you're getting it yeah so
I that on me Amy the department did send
that to me I didn't realize it was going
to be part of their presentation to so
that's my
fault okay so moving on the next page is
the next document in your pocket is a um
summary of these are
um these are pro programs within the
budget book the page number is on listed
on here as well most of these are
federal um accounting units and a
description of um what that program is
as well as the RSA that um that um
supports that initiative and so I
thought that given how many we have 134
accounting units and I thought to get
through the budget book this would help
support information regarding the
federal funds and what programs we have
so it would give you a resource
later cuity was this already part of
your slide deck or is this a separate
thing no this is new and I did not send
this on yet so I will do that we just
put this together great you just send
the PDF any have that that's fine not
not right now
okay I'm blaming you
okay so jumping into the budget
book so Department of Safety we start on
page 339 it's the bottom of the page
there's no data on that
page so it really starts on page 340
so as you go when you make references to
page numbers and all could you also
provide me account numbers because I'm
looking at this in a different way than
you
are it's 11:23 I me I figure that one
out but okay yes absolutely um so and
stop and correct me if you want me to
explain more on these how we approach
this is really looking for changes of
10% um on either direction um to get
through this but if you want specific
information on anyone line just ask okay
but that's how I'll go through this that
sounds great okay perfect that'll keep
it
moving yeah so on on this page um so
just quickly for reference so the this
is the office of the commissioner um
with a 20.4 million um stop for fiscal
year 26 in 20.6 million for fiscal year
27 37% of this is allocated to salary
and benefits and um operating costs are
Federal grant Awards processed mostly by
office of Highway Safety and Homeland so
on um accounting uh account code 38 you
see the the difference of
35,000 that is software um being
purchased for the
iak excuse me so are you looking at just
the the
account that you mentioned there
yep and that description of 1123 is also
on your the sheet that I handed out
about what that but didn't you say
something about 24 million that's the
overall budget for the um Commissioner's
Office okay so you're way
down that's at the end so the sorry the
the office of the commissioner runs from
page 340 to
348 so I'm looking at the office of
commissioner total I still don't see 24
million
it's probably for the
bani 348 the 26 27 toal all the
Commissioner's Office oh okay so don't
don't don't do banal totals because
those are no no no no no you can jump
ahead but don't use banal totals because
apparently you don't put those into your
spreadsheet they're not they don't
appear in the spreadsheet so okay I get
it now
okay so you just going to skip that this
this whole commissioner section because
it's not really so this is you okay that
I'm fine with that okay so I'm GNA so
just let me know when you're doing that
so I can scan quickly to the end of the
okay all the accounts so um page 341 and
accounting unit 20 um
2298 is Homeland Security grants that is
also federal funds questions on this
page page
342 this is
3082 so this is the office of the Bureau
of hearings um so this is out of the
commissioner's office as well um so some
of the activity heing changes
um let me
see it's all federal
so if I may just it would be easier if
when you refer to the page we also bring
up that four-digit account code in this
case we are on page 342 on account 3082
yes some of us navigate with page
numbers some of them navigate with
accounts and this will smooth things
over and seriously we appreciate it
so I'm not seeing many changes in
3082 um do you have any questions about
that
account
503 same page
342 the um the I think the largest
change there is in um 30 um 030 and
that's a car that's replacement car due
to age and Miles this is a question to
the committee um if it's under a million
dollars of total expenses are you
comfortable going pass it or you under
half million dollars what
number under a million in a rule yeah
sure in okay there may be so un unless
you see a reason to stop at one of these
because the expenses are lower than a
million dollars maybe just like go ahead
and gloss right over them because a lot
of these this this one here is like
$400,000 or half million there 3 ,000
and half a million
so okay 7541 seems to be the
first large
one yeah go
ahead only adjust did you the oh
no oh there it is the button was red the
mic didn't work anyway so the only
adustment I would suggest to what the
chairman is saying we want to focus on
the larger amounts cuz for obvious
reasons but if there is something that's
under the threshold that has some
meaningful changes please don't hesitate
to stop on it you know but otherwise
yeah we can uh stuff like aerial safety
I'm sure it's an important topic but
budget wise it doesn't seem to be a
significant expenditure so we can I hope
they won't feel insulted when we skip
over it pretty much okay certainly so
I'm correcting that 7541 that that is
the office of Highway Safety that is
another um Federal grant program so they
um so the changes there let me see there
um hiring you can skip those two sorry I
didn't see notice it was
Federal
7542 that is
federal I think
commissioner big chunks big
chunks it's going
okay can I a question yes Murray yeah um
on my page 347 this is under the alcohol
andair driving is that a new Grant from
the federal line
102 200,000 this year and then 200,000
next and next is that just a a new
Federal Grant
shoot trying to find where 743 alcohol
impaired driving number 102 it's not a
large amount I'm just curious to know if
we got a new
Grant I I wouldn't call them new grants
there's new opportunities that you know
take place but I would say that's just
you know reapplying what we've done in
the past alcohol impairment
so now we're on page well actually we're
um to the division of administration I'm
on page
2318 but I'm not seeing a large change
here
350 it's a whole bunch of them there you
can slide
past all federal funds anyway oh no no
you I got Highway funds down
here wh I see you got
highway I think now
DN well
um so so when you get to 20 did you go
right past 23
what is that
2190 oh sorry that's on a different
department okay so what happens
after
4244 can you give me the account
number
23310 this just the four digits
I see that's
FAL represent hacken
Phillips um I'm just very curious on
page
353 um 11
driver pay is for when they actually
work on that holiday
other questions on this AU
so I'm through with DMV and didn't
find any any
other I I agree just a so that's a
Department of Motor Vehicles right
correct yes so just I don't know what
was there but in terms of a question I
have for you not not to answer now but
um I'd like to know what fees since like
registration fees um those kinds of
things the department has and when they
were last changed modified and how many
uh per year do you process for licenses
or registrations or you know
whatever thank you oh and if they go
into an account other than the straight
highway fund if they have some sort of a
dedicated fund associated with them
okay or unrestricted fund that's the
right word
the division of um New Hampshire State
Police starts on page 358 and runs
through Page
389 so changes there
are pretty small what's this one federal
grants repres
Murray me no no no I don't um um I don't
if I let me know if I skipped too far
ahead I'm looking at the Cold Case unit
and um it looks like you've got page uh
my page is
361 and the unit the Cold Case unit is1
1876 and you've got um you're buying
something next
year what's your question representative
Mar on the C case unit equipment Unity
what is the the 9 93,000 you're getting
new equipment for the Cold Case unit we
we currently have two auxiliary Troopers
and one full-time State Police
Lieutenant assigned in the C case unit
this is equipment 30 is a fleet vehicle
vehicle for the record it's not as much
the cost of the vehicle when I was
equipping police cruisers it was all the
other equipment you had to to put on
them just to make it clear that it's not
just go to the lot and pay the dealer
for a truck so thank
you was making snip
marks guys they come here
and yeah I have a few questions about um
page
362 uh unit 2 64 the substance of use
enforcement section um I'm seeing some
pretty big changes so maybe you could
walk us through
um um specifically personnel and then
rent leases equipment
replacement that's pretty much the the
ones that Drew the most attention to me
when we I went through this the first
time
transfers oh actually I'm sorry I have
them um so for the Personnel the
decrease is we unfunded two
positions and the equipment
I have that we decrease the equipment
purchases and the rent but I don't have
the list of what equipment that um was
planned for that was um
removed do you have
it the fleet vehicles
sign of Murray is this part of your
attempts to meet the governor's targets
is this yeah
okay so nobody has any permits and
Licensing moving forward
2913 several probably several Pages
forward
did you just tell us what that's about
and because that sounds like a place
where you're doing permits and Licensing
which would bring fees in I'm not
mistaken
yes is there a question sir can you say
what so what what permits what licenses
what are we talking about here so that's
permits and Licensing that unit um
commonly sometimes is the gun line which
does approval for gun purchases they
also license security guards and um Bail
Enforcement agents and so they all the
permits and licensing on those too
that's the gun line I got it okay
roban Murray are we moving to the next
page I was curious about the substance
abuse enforcement the granite Shield
what happened to 20125 why is that
zeroed out7
now now it's part of HD one that's in
the
budget
expens sure if you want to go ahead
and what is what account is it related
[Music]
to right which account in the budget EX
so uh the northern Shield was
incorporated into accounting unit um
3077 which is the one you were
questioning about um there was no 25
budget that got built into that
accounting
unit that's good I
Mr chair yes so the representative
hacken Phillips is correct so section 70
Northern shield on page 42 of House Bill
two does relate to this accounting unit
so I think the department could just
speak to the 1.8 and $1.7 million the
source of funds where that's coming from
and what is kind of being proposed here
that page 40 section 70 so starting on
line 22
SE I don't know what
sectioning 42 p
no I it's a got it sorry it's right here
thought you said 70 I'm going
crazy so the half million dollars that's
being talked about in hb2 that's a
component of what we see in the grants
non-federal for count 3077
I'm on now M just came back that's very
strange
I guess my concern is that uh if I'm
reading the right
section that there's plans to use part
of the opioid abatement trust fund for
Department of Safety purchases or
purposes
um and my understanding was that the
opioid abatement trust fun was to combat
like I guess um you know like patient
care essentially like to
prevent folks for from even um you know
I guess from like recovery and substance
abuse treat treatment essentially but in
this case it's really just
enforcement um and my question is
shouldn't uh division 3 be taking a look
as well at this um policy
change considering I I don't believe the
trust fund in the past has been used for
safety
purposes you any thoughts or Mickey uh
no we could ask division three for their
comments on on this section um I I don't
know if the department wants to speak to
um the intent and why that source of
fund is being used for this purpose I
think it's a new the new uh
first time we've used this for
enforcement but I'll let the department
speak to
that um historically this has been a
generally funded accounting unit and
during the governor's space it um the
funding was
updated um it was updated
um for the governor's
office I would just say I think this
program is critical and um you know i'
defer to to policy makers on how it's
funded and you know I don't think I'm
prepared to speak in great detail of the
opiod de batement I understand with the
dollars there but my goal is to just
find the dollars to keep this program
running so basically I'm sorry Rob m i I
say I'm U I think my concern is that um
the money is being acred for
opioid abatement programs and not law
enforcement programs and so there seems
to be a shift of of the way the money is
supposed to be used um I'm fine with it
being appropriated but that it be used
for opioid abatement programs as opposed
to law
enforcement I think that that's would be
my question did you and were you saying
the governor is the one who made the
shift with this or it was during the
governor's phase yeah
okay I still have a objection to um and
a substance abuse fund that is used for
treatment being used for law
enforcement I think that's why I think
division three should weigh in on that
Port you know portion I it's not that
the it's not that the activity or the
program is not worthy of funding it's
just I'm not sure this is the correct
funding
mechanism um so I'd be willing to hear
their thoughts in terms of um so could
just make a not that Mickey and and REM
remind me to talk to Jess and see if he
wants to look at that as
well yes and I would say uh perhaps the
department could just so 500,000 a year
of this appropriation would be earmarked
for Northern Shield the remaining 1.3
just to make sure the committee knows
what that would be used for too sure so
this really is to um address the needs
of the entire state so what we did was
when we looked at um currently right now
we have and I'll say you know separate
from northern Shield the North Country
we have um many different police
departments that engage in this we have
have a total of 40 Partners to address
the needs the emerging needs that we're
seeing in the North Country we um carved
out and I I think it's an excellent idea
um specific funds to support Coos
Grafton Carol and Sullivan counties and
to create a a a team up there a new team
Northern Shield to address that and um
and combat the um the opio issues and
other dangerous drugs in the North
country as you know working up there um
is is presents different challenges with
how hard it is to get you know police
officers and and resources from the
southern part of the state up there so
this was um this was a special car vote
for them and I will tell you that um
there have been significant seizures up
there there are issues up there the
drugs are there so um I think this is
going to be a new model I think it's
going to be better and I think in the
end it'll be um it'll be highly
impactful to addressing the needs in the
North
country further questions on that or at
this
point Y all right so scanning
ahead represent D Roy yes of course uh
with President Trump's announcement last
night or back along where he's going to
be putting tariffs on Canada for not
stopping the drugs coming over the
Border do you think that's going to make
a difference for
you I couldn't comment on on I don't
think I can comment on what might happen
but I will comment on today we have a
problem today that needs to be addressed
okay thank
you I do have a followup done um how
many how many um can you quantify the
current problem in these in particular
to these counties um that you coming
from
Canada is there a direct link are are
you asking me what drugs are flowing
from the north down yeah you just said
there was a problem today so I'm just
wondering what qu like how to quantify
it I I can clear I can clear that up I
think it's a good question um I didn't
I'm not speaking to the source of supply
of drugs but I know that there has been
a significant Source coming from the
south from States outside um I can't
quantify how much of the drugs are
coming from Canada down but um they are
seeing fentanyl they're seeing cocaine
they're seeing methamphetamine they're
experiencing overdose deaths and they're
trying their best to work together
amongst themselves create a North
Country team um so um I I would say that
the majority of the drugs that we're
seeing the fenel are coming um from the
South but it's what you don't know what
you also don't know is what might have
come over so I couldn't quantify that
but I would say I think predominantly
the drugs have been coming we're seeing
them coming from the
south so the next one where I see
significant General funds is account
5412 the detective
Bureau and I know that I can't remember
your name but your wonderful
assistant
Amy the lady at the in the white that's
Amy
were you were very good in providing
live of information about this when I
met you several weeks ago and a question
I have regarding this you move six State
Police from Highway to general fund and
it made sense to me what you're doing
there or what the governor was doing
there oh I
don't sorry I can't go the wrong way the
other way
384 what page sir
what's the page number 384 384 3
sorry
it's Department of Transportation thank
you and what was the question
representative Earth okay I haven't
gotten to that but here it is okay okay
so um I understand why the governor
moved the six positions from a highway
fund to the general fund and from one
detective Bureau group to another
detective Bureau group correct so there
were nine there were actually nine
transfers okay but I believe you told me
that was six of them were in the
detective to detective and the other
three were some other yep so there so
State Police um wanted to they the
transfers were made to better align the
um detectives to to better align the
positions within the troop stations and
the um detective Bureau so that's what
happened there a decision made by the
state police oh so maybe my question
will be moo so having because it looked
like the highway fund is
very uh tight on
budget so I thought that was one of the
reasons that the adjustment was made no
no it was a decision State Police made
to um to uh align the to better align
the positions with the work they're
doing in the in within the troop
stations okay so having more money in
the highway fund wouldn't incline you to
put them back there and get get them off
the general fund okay there are
detectives in the troops as well so
there's Patrol Troopers but then they
have troop detectives within the troop
right no I saw detectives in both I
thought well maybe I could just shift
them back there and get my general funds
back but you're suggesting
no you got to do your you got you got to
try
right so that was my only question did
anybody else have any other questions
there because that's where there's a big
transfer an additional nine
people that's right
687 no don't the questions
there oh you okay you're good yeah okay
all right so I'll move
on so I guess we're done with this
division of State Police did I miss
something
that was
easy what is next in terms of the
book so on page um 389 to 404 is
Homeland Security and Emergency
Management you'll find a in this
division um is a lot of federal funding
as well
no 59
representative whatever M you just call
me Kate can you just explain and perhaps
it's obvious and I missed it
empg Emergency Management man
performance grants performance grants
okay
I
can so the purpose of this um this is
these are federal dollars um and it is
to local communities for Emergency
Management performance they provide
technical assistance and grant funding
to local communities it the performance
um grant program plays an important role
in implementation of national
preparedness systems by supporting
building sustainment um and delivery of
core capabilities essential to achieving
National preparedness goal and secure
and resilient
Nation so that act that whole activity
is mostly federal funds other than that
that one I raised the concern
about so what is the next one in the
book
you have a question yeah go ahead um
page my my page 414
under
uh yeah I can't even find the unit it's
at the bottom of my page um 5006
mechanical safety is that a transfer
from someplace else that's a
transfer that's a division that's an hb2
thing with that's the oplc thing isn't
it oplc so that is the transfer of
mechanical and electrical engineers and
that's a transfer of the positions
program and Appropriations
whose decision was that or is what's the
reasoning behind
that moving the people basically from
oplc over to so I think safy it's really
about aligning the work um so I I
believe this unit used to be with safety
I can't tell you which year that was I
think three Bs
ago it's really aligning the work
they're going back and
forth okay
okay so we now in the fire safety
activity is that where we
are we skipped over desk did you have
any questions about death um desk it's
the um uh Emergency Services um for like
911 you had questions when we came La
last
time account number oh um 1395
404 yeah I am inged Mr sh can I ask a
couple questions of course um so I
assume this is the from the hb2 draft
like the initial draft I assume this is
related to the section at the end what
is that 23 section 23 of the Department
of
Safety that's correct great um yeah I do
have some questions
um so it appears that the radio
communications State radio
communications is being enveloped and
expanded into the
911 sech charge funding
mechanism uh maybe we could talk about
the purpose of why that's happening and
what past practice has
been so page page 63 of House Bill 2
Section 149 is what representative
hacken Phillips is referring
to so um the notes provided by um the
division were that um they currently
support the radio communication so this
just um
uh it provide the search
charge um having this built into the
statute so that it would be clear that
the um 911 over sees the radio
communication function and allows
expenditures that state or federal funds
for the um for the state radio system it
would also provide the search charge
funds that would also be used for radio
communication maintenance so it's just
Clarity of what they currently
do and maybe you could describe what the
current state radio communications
include and how that's Rel relateded to
911 emergencies we have so so at at a
high level the Statewide radio system I
believe rides on 47 sites microwave
repeaters radios towers and there's a
loop so that's our state system there
are other agencies that run on that with
which is critical for obviously Public
Safety so the the division of emergency
services and Communications that
overseas 911 director Doyle two BPS so
the calls come in to 911 and it's
important to make sure that after the
calls come in that the um that help is
sent to where it's needed so that rides
on the radio system all of those
employees all of that infrastructure
that entire Radio Network right now
Falls within the division of emergency
services and Communications so the tie
between that and we can give you more on
this offline the tie between that system
the crit critical importance of that
that as it ties to 911 and life safety
with you know providing resources and
help I think is something that um I
think what they're trying to do is just
make sure to show the connection between
the two and um but we've looked at other
other you know agencies other states and
how those two are connected so your
question is well that's one system and
then the other system is um is cellular
or landline calling 911 but really the
whole the whole um the radio system
Falls Within DEC the tower climbers the
network that it runs on and there are
redundant capabilities within there that
benefit um benefit both
so it's really all under there
representative now it all falls within
that
division does this allow the
911 the people taking 911 calls to then
directly access this this other network
so they can well well they're actually
they're forwarding these calls they're
these calls but then the calls need to
go to you know the dispatch centers the
fire wherever and then right so is this
helping are you tying the network
together so the 911 people can directly
communicate with the police or other
Emergency Services I I I think you can
say that but to be technical of how it's
done I would like to provide that to you
okay as opposed to just um saying
yes I think we can provide the
information that you're looking for
there are two separate systems but it is
it's somewhat complicated but I believe
that they um with without both working
together the system doesn't
work when you say work together well
well well I say working working
functioning but you need a radio network
you need a radio system so that you can
send the First Responders and they can
communicate right but you also need to
have the 911 people have access to that
system correct absolutely okay and
that's what you'll confirm for us well
yes but they're not they're not they
don't have access to a radio system
they're not disat batching from 911
they're forwarding calls to back to her
question sure represent D so I know one
of the problems that we're having in
straford County up straford county is
that we don't have cell phone coverage
we don't have towers and our police are
having a hard time when they're going
over to Middleton and other places are
you finding that throughout New
Hampshire especially up north that it's
difficult to communicate yeah so so
again we have um there are separate
systems throughout the state you know
there's County systems it's our state
system which we just talk about um um we
call it what used to be btop uh Knick
neck so it's our system we we have cores
in that system our radio system that
allows the counties to communicate to to
tie into that so it expands
interoperability so when you use the
word interoperability that means
different things to different people but
um our nwor does expand and we want to
make sure that um some are self-reliant
but it's tying them all together so but
it's all it's different issues it's the
coverage is one thing but I can't speak
to the straford county I think they have
a they have a very good Dispatch Center
straford County so um you know they
would dispatch for um you know I
couldn't tell you who dispatches for DOA
who dispatches for for you know I know
that um they're separate
though I have a follow of course so um
maybe you could describe what state
radio communication systems are who uses
it and
um is there a chance that State Radio
communication systems do not include 911
emergency
requirements do not include do you mean
do not include in what respect funding
or policy or when you say do not include
if you so you're currently it appears
that the governor's proposal in hb2 is
to pay for State Radio communication
systems by 911 emergency funds and my
question isops I missed who's using the
state radio communications system and
does that Communications radio system
have requirements that do not include
911 emergencies sure and what are these
employees doing that will be funded out
of those 911 funds and how do they serve
not only the radio network but 911 in it
of itself because that's what you're
looking at it's the employees it's the
the radio technicians the tower climbers
the equipment uh it's it's pretty much
everything it's the entire we can we can
provide
that I would love more information about
this thank you
absolutely yeah I guess you know to that
point it would be clearer to me since
these are two different systems if you
can um identify the different revenue
streams that go into into this
so as as part of that I think we can do
that now I think it's the SE charge the
911 SE charge so it's a 911
fund and so there's no funding at all
for the State Radio communication
systems other than
that no I think they're all on
that we've been using the e911 funds for
this for years there's no change it's
just clean
up for how long did you say for years
three years yes Years thank you
four years I assume that means many or
at least more than
two we we'll we'll provide that at
representative
aens okay so now we up to the fire
safety activity
should I forget what page that was on
maybe 14
50006 and then maybe before
that or
13 fire safety is the first one
fire standards training and EMS starts
on page 408 with accounting unit
465 oh
okay that's that
so both fire standards training EMS and
the fire Marshall's office is primarily
funded through fees collected um by
providing copies of Motor Vehicle
records and certificates as authorized
under RSA 260 subsection 14
and these records are typically
requested by insurance companies and
other authorized entities and if you
recall the last time we were here um we
talked about the request that um of $4
million to be put into the um fire fund
the dedicated fund to support activity
of the fire Marshall's office this fund
is not healthy to support both fire
standards training in EMS and the fire
Marshall's office so that 4 million has
been included into this
budget you'll see that on page
418 page 418 and county unit
6631 does it show up in revolving funds
is that where
the the fire fund Appropriations appear
as revolving funds that general fund 4
million is a general fund appropriation
there is a house bill 2 Section that
says any amount of that 400 or excuse me
$4 million that is not expended in 26
won't lapse back to the general fund
it'll actually lapse to the fire fund so
all $4 million will eventually be
benefit of the fire fund right so I
understood all that from our previous
conversations but where do I see the
four million in the 65 account it's not
it's in 6631
oh why do I
have comments
here it
is does 4065 also drw from that font I
have notes that tie these two together
correct they they both pull off of um
the dedicated fund the fire
fund okay so the dedicated fund is
referred to as a revolving fund is that
accurate yes okay SO3 003 is that fund
at least as far as it as this account is
concerned correct okay I got my notes
right so where are you all 66
yep the other half of it okay that's the
other half I got
that I have a small question about um
the mechanical safety unit
5006 so I noticed there were a lot of
zeros in
2024 and adjusted 2025 um it's like page
4454 and 415 excuse
me
um I guess could we have a little
background about uh why it wasn't funded
before and why it is
now this is the one that's oh that's the
oplc okay okay thank 25 are accounted
for Inc
budget thank you
so I'm lost as of how far you guys
got where are youall CU you're bouncing
back and
forth it's a bit
chotic you're Gra so where are we
officially right now in reviewing this
just to try to bring everybody on the
same page cuz I'm pretty sure we are in
slightly different places everywhere
across the table last question asked had
to do with the p it was page 415 on 56
right but previous questions were
further down below so I'm just trying to
figure out where we are sequentially
more or less
here I'm good just wanted to Anchor
myself a little that's
all gu my question what's the next
activity I'm on 427 it's
my 7546
that's federal
funds well well we are going down the
page on page 418 uh unit 6631 the fire
safety administration we talked about
earlier at some point just a quick
question on the
um bouncy nature of the 050 line so page
418 account 6631 line
050 the personal service temporary
appointment again low number in 24 quite
high in 25 returning to the
middle and while we talk about that I'm
sure the benefits are partly related to
that so we could maybe talk about them
both at the same time just trying to
understand what's going
on 6
uh yes account 6631 line is 50 and uh
okay up to the 900 60
yeah I'll have to get back with you no
worry I mean my best guess right now
would be that maybe you use less in a
first year and then you carry the
budgeted and then you budget in the
middle but just to be sure I don't like
assuming I would rather be sure you know
so followup is amazing
yeah yeah basically it's you
know again it could could be that you're
ear six something on average and you
didn't burn it here and you are stashing
it here because it's a two-year budget
and all that so that's what it looks
like but I want to be
sure if I was the 46 yeah that's what I
would bet
426 because the position don't change so
do questional is that tempor it may not
be in the positions you know yeah
scooting ahead and hopefully won't go
back back again but I didn't have
anything until uh the legal unit uh
starting on it's 9002 on 427 um there's
the increase in Personnel looks like
you've hired three new people can you
talk to the three new people you've
hired or is this a transfer as well
certainly we moved three positions from
State Police so one was uh pargal um so
let me see one was a paralal from the
detective Bureau one was a a paralal
moved from the traffic Bureau and one
was moved from State Police
Communications this this was done to um
address 91a requests so these additional
employees were needed to get placed in
the legal unit to address a demand and
increase in 91a but there's it's not
actually an increase overall in it's
just reassigning them to different um or
different agency different function
right okay thank you
oh sorry to bounce um page
419 uh unit um the expenditure total for
fire safety I was looking at the
uh source of
funds so 48010 20 you know the fire
safety page
it's in the current budget it's uh more
other funds than very little from the
general fund and then it flips over I
was wondering if that's just a you know
budgeting device for now and you expect
that general fund number to drop or is
it a ongoing change in the way that uh
unit is funded so again on page 419 the
source of
funds for the general fund in
uh 2024 2025 it's almost all from the
other funds and then it becomes mostly
from the general fund in 26 going back
to mostly other funds in 27 this is
related to the house bill 2 language
where we're um appropriating $4 million
General funds um into this fire fund
okay sorry so I just missed it when it
was covered earlier thank you for
pointing that out I really appreciate it
that's okay I you know it's a long day
thank you
all the Commissioners next
are we into the division of
administration okay okaye I'm in the
right place
big changes
here out of the
person is the new person
in uh what is that account 2190 a
transfer or new fire or new position
it is a
transfer you know where from from which
account I have this one coming from it's
a state police
transfer go ahead yes oh it sounds like
everyone's transferring out of state
police it seems all the transfers you've
spoken to oh this they're all from State
Police is there a reason for
that well I mean quite honestly when we
had to address the 91a I think we looked
across the whole department to see where
we could come up with some positions um
the majority of the work the majority of
the 91a requests come in um deal with
State Police um nobody wants to give
positions up so we have to really do the
best we can and look and see um you know
where we can um where we can pull them
from so the position here it's
transferring into Administration um is
actually really align we're trying to
align more of the um Financial work the
Contracting work the procurement work
and so this position within State Police
does a lot of that work and we're
pulling it into Administration we're
doing that throughout the department
trying to gain efficiencies in that way
good question
though
[Laughter]
pleas that one doesn't seem to have too
much
look I asked unrelated question oh go go
go yes sorry we're all getting swamped
with um emails around vehicle
registration and you know this the
inspections safety inspections for that
there's the bill to eliminate the safety
inspections um some of the emails that I
get and I mean this I'm sure we've all
just gotten so many of them um one of
the issues which I would be sensitive to
I support having the inspections frankly
i' like to know that the car's on on the
road or you know in working condition um
especially having had a car hit me that
was not um but one of the concerns is
scamming people around vehicle
inspections and I've never even seen
that that's it's it's not an expensive
thing for me to do it doesn't it takes
half an hour to an hour who's in charge
of enforcing or looking into when
someone feels they've been scammed
around a state inspection for their car
so so that that's a
that's a good question I'll try and
answer it so the inspection process in
and of itself um is is supported by
rules like what is an inspection so we
uh at the department of safety we
license the um the dealers we license
the mechanics we license those that are
approved to do an inspection if somebody
does not do the required inspection and
puts an inspection sticker on a vehicle
and our automotive equipment inspectors
who work out of the DMV with Troop G
which is the commercial uh Troopers a
complaint can be filed an
investigation's done and it could result
in a hearing and then eventually it
would come to my office where the person
could be you know face some action be it
suspended have their license taken away
I think your question about if they went
in I would direct you to the Attorney
General's office with the with the
consumer Bureau uh in other words I
don't but but you could also um you
could also steer that as well um to to
uh I would say to the to the inspect
inspectors because it could come down to
not only the inflating cost but the
inspection itself wasn't done accurately
so I think you have two venues there to
look at you could look at the
enforcement side and then the Attorney
General's office um for on the consumer
issue yeah I have some sensitivity
towards the person who's been scammed as
it were that their car is perfectly fine
for passing inspection and it doesn't
because of this because of that because
of this and so they end up instead of
paying $49 they pay $400 and for a lot
of those people they don't necessarily
have the resources in order
to um address the fact that they've been
um taken advantage of in that way so my
concern is more with that person who's
been overcharged for unnecessarily
unnecessary work but once we do it um
aren't usually more work done it's less
work like it has an inspection sticket
but it didn't pass the emissions test or
there were issues with brakes or you
know surface rust whatnot but there's a
pretty um robust team so I would forward
them I can provide you the numbers we
can provide the numbers to make you like
who they would
call so so we toward are we
DMV
yep I
2926 in DMV uh account what is that
2311 the agenc the income is that
obviously a dedicated fund of some type
I'm sorry what your counting unit 3100
2311 page
438 page
438 um it's cost cost of collections
cost of collections oh that's right
which is you tell me what that is so
just a reminder to everybody the cost of
collections Highway fund when we hear
about that term here per the con tion
and by state law and by state budget the
department of safety's uh road toll
Bureau some agency indirect and then all
basically all of DMV is funded by the
revenue it collects so it it deducts its
cost of collecting and administering
Highway funds then turns over the net to
the highway fund as unrestricted Revenue
so when you see agency income here in
201311 that's essentially Highway funds
as far as hitting the the net bottom
line of the highway fund and just to
make sure under did correctly it's
essentially Highway funds but it's
Highway funds that never actually get
given there they will collected as
Highway funds and retained as the cost
of doing business by the agency before
the rest of the proceedings are put in
the highway funds so if you have your
Surplus statements with you that we
talked about this morning and passed out
before uh sorry Melanie I'm going sneak
under here so if you have that handy
you'll see that Revenue projections are
done on a gross basis so house waying
means does a grow Revenue estimate for
road toll motor vehicle fees and then
you'll see the line line eight on this
document which is the Department of
safety's cost of collections backs out
of that and then the net of that is what
goes as unrestricted Highway fund
Revenue they
just so in total just looking at this
document in fiscal 26 about $38 million
uh of cost of collections Appropriations
are in this document that you're going
pay my page
through how we doing page number of
pages versus time say that again can you
tell where we are number of pages versus
time you're you're on much better Pace
than you were this
morning good job
team for the record we are 100 pages in
in one hour and a half or less and we
are 30 pages away from the end so you
need to slow down and ask many
questions so so step St
up any want Toc me if need be if you
feel Need need Okay so Motor
Registration is the same
idea so this is great so this this would
be the department where there looks like
there's a lot of things that people pay
for okay good so that's what you'll be
telling me about
awesome and along with that you might
make some if you are comfortable making
some recommendations as
aware maybe fees should be increased yes
sir thank
you this is what you get for encouraging
me um General comment not a question per
se I do appreciate that in many ways the
department is self funded because they
collect funds and they retain what they
need to operate and they send the rest
to the highway fund
right that's obviously I know that you
working hard to still cut cost because
every dollars that you guys don't need
to retain is a dollar that goes to the
highway fund which is in a not great
shape financially overall so I just
wanted to emphasize for you guys because
I know you are already doing it but the
importance of continuing to look for way
to cut cost even though you do have the
funds to operate because every dollar
you guys use to collect those funds is a
dollar that later we don't have it to
spend so you know being a revenue
generator is great but we could always
generate more Revenue if we spend even
less to do the same job as long as
that's possible and I know that you are
squeezing that Penny really hard so I'm
not worried but you know since we seem
to have 30 seconds to spare thank you
I'm done well you know just just a
followup when you bring that up I I
think it's a good point when you use the
term operate just at a high level with
the DMV so you've just you know Mickey
gave you the um overview on cost of
collections but when I look at what
director morasco and his leadership team
are in charge of over there with the
Licensing Bureau the registration Bureau
the titling Bureau pushing out these um
passenger license exams and Commercial
Motor Vehicles exams and the customer
service is critical ensuring that not
only can they do it um they can meet the
needs of the customers but they can do
it you know securely and safely so we
always look at what we try and do is
balance the customer service and
ensuring that and when we look at the
DMV you things are increasing you know
the demand for services are increasing
so there's a great deal of uh emphasis
put on customer service and how quickly
we can turn these titles around how
quickly people can get their cars
registered get their licenses done new
drivers take their test their skills
test their their their uh road test and
so it's a balance there but we've we've
tried to do everything we can to ensure
that that level of service will be what
your constituents you know have been
used to absolutely and when I mean
operating I mean operating at the level
expected by our constituents and by the
people who pay all those fees and taxes
who have a right to expect good service
so absolutely no So speaking of
constituent service this reminded me of
something I think I brought to you
before where one of my
constituents uh was went through the
small claims court and got to the point
where the judge issued a um bench
warrant and it came back to the
constituent oh you got to get the guy's
birth a you recall this convers ation I
do and I had a follow up with the courts
immediately after this so I also have
followed up with the Supreme Court and
I've not yet I I the DMV provided a form
to them eventually which uh this person
has filled out and send back but we've
heard nothing back since then so is she
going to get that birth
date again I I made I made a phone call
contemporaneous to this meeting and I'll
I'll follow up again okay cuz the DMV
eventually provided the court
with a their their form um that would
request the to request the birth date
and that was returned and um maybe
offline sir we can work on this and I
can look at the particular case and okay
see where it's at thank
you yes of course represent Murray um
while you know we're picking your brains
on some of these things um and you have
impact on the highway fund and the
highway fund certainly impacts you uh
what is your views on equitably managed
managing electric cars uh in terms of
their Road
usage we're all looking for good ideas
here
about so I mean are you looking for what
the Fe should be it imp the highway fund
electric vehicles are not paying the the
gas tax going to you know usage of the
road but my car uses the road and I know
that there's there's some sort of a c
tax or charge now is that sufficient is
that Equitable is that you know is that
the right direction which to go I guess
I'm looking for opinions on how you
manage um electric vehicle usage on the
road because they don't use gas but they
sure use the roads I I know assistant
commissioner Lavoy has looked into this
a little and I'll I'll defer I'll
provide some followup from him so that
we can give you better information it's
a good good question but they have been
looking at this but I'm not prepared to
give a number
now so we have to Comm commcial
enforcement division of State
Police number our count 305 which is
Page
448 n
thereabouts just want to make sure I'm
synced up with everybody
else so you dropped a couple of
positions
in
2305 I guess that's page
448 we unfunded 15 positions here to
meet the targets
15 so in addition
to this is Page 448 and it's accounting
unit
2305 so your permanent classified shows
52 down to 50 but then you unfunded a
bunch of those is that what you're
saying on top of that 15 so you reduced
two you limited two positions completely
and then you unfunded 15
that's a good question is
traffic she's getting it if you can give
her one minute no that's fine which
count the same I'm looking at
2305 so the count so looks she reduced
two two are gone unless they're part of
the transfers they are part of the
transfers they transfers yes so two are
transfers and 15 were unfunded correct
okay so it's been reduced to transferred
to
and what and what's the vacancy in that
department out of the 50 or
52 I can give you that that's Troop G so
and actually enforcement spreads across
different um troops so we can provide
that okay
that's probably in your big chart you
gave me too I just thought you might
help
it off the top of your head but I I I
will say this the but that's a good
question so that wasn't actually an a
very good answer I think the colonel
when he has done these transfers I think
it's important to understand that as
we're
moving uh positions as we're unfunded
positions looking forward with what we
have funded he understands the needs of
the division of State Police in troops a
through G what we need in the
specialized units detectives which is
5412 uh major crime unit crime scene so
he balances this out it seems
complicated with all the different
position numbers funding you know
funding sources for how they fund the
Troopers but the colonel does a good job
with looking at how do I run the
division of State Police and where do I
need Troopers so it's actually um but
but that's really his responsibility so
while you hear a number so high in one
when you look at the seven troops which
is operations you know across the state
he it's really it's his job to balance
it out and I and I and I know he
has
decrease State Police Communications is
this related to what we were talking
about earlier
2927 they're conversation about
Communications radio the I believe these
are
dispatchers okay so so not related to
the separate okay separate okay all
right um so there's a decrease
there only one person but but about half
the general funds which I love but I'm
wondering what's happening there I don't
want to get ahead of direct to Newbery
so what page are you on 450
yeah I'm actually not page I'll get to
it oh that's good though that's what
they really
did taking
out so that's good
yeah Trump I got a big boost right good
good good
good so the reduction in Personnel here
is one position moved to Legal the
transfer but as a so okay great thank
you as a general
question represent Murray was just
pointing out that the the funding while
appearing flat in total is shifting from
General over to Turnpike and and and and
Highway which is is
fantastic how is that able to happen
here we can't make it happen
everywhere sure I think she's looking it
up but you can certainly have while
you're looking at up um I'm slightly
less enthusiastic about the use of
Highway funds because we will at some
point have to put General funds money to
the highway fund so if we take it from
one end and put it back into another
we're not
really increase fees baby I'm that
Highway until that funding is fixed yes
fine fine fine yes but obviously higher
use of Turnpike funds is nice again
because it does relieve a burden on the
general fund and I'll let you finish
looking up the answer to the original
question
but look if we can plug that great but
until we I celebrate that's fine so we
we were provided a target for um turn P
funds as well but this is just a shift
and fund mix so we have um the same fund
mix across different accounting units
for flexibility to move appropriation if
needed for the next B so we didn't add
more turn f um right which is which is
great so my question sort of is we we
must have the same
flexibility if you have it we have
it correct you
okay so what do we need to know in terms
of which accounts have that flexibility
I assume it's not just any account has
correct they need to be geared towards
um uh supporting um Tas towards the turn
fighte funds so we we can we can provide
that um accounting units that are
restricted specifically um to from that
source of fund okay okay to well to
Mickey yes yeah right go ahead mickeey
if you have a comment
we've got we we've got in the budget
here the accounts that have used
turnpikes in the P Turnpike funds in the
past okay um we don't have a defined
limit necessarily but there the
Department of Transportation would
probably ask you to exercise some uh
caution with just using a ton of
Turnpike funds for other purposes beyond
what we're already doing for state
police enforcement and of those roads I
I I get it and I'd like to as much
caution as I can but I still need to
balance the budget okay so I'm just
trying to open up as many doors as
possible not trying to jump through all
of them
but so and just to add a bit more color
obviously the turnpike funds for example
have to be managed carefully because we
have to keep them at a certain level we
got to make sure they match the revenues
and so on but at the end of the day this
is
a a tough budget which is hopefully a
one-time tough budget because we are
hoping the economy will turn around
so if there are funds where we have a
bit of flexibility in terms of treating
them for the lack of a better word as a
you know emergency fund or whatever
Reserve fund or what not this may be the
year when we may be a bit more willing
to you know look into those
possibilities with a hope of you know
reducing our draw from them in the next
budget so we don't continue to drain
them at the you know un usually
frustrate so I'm not saying that I have
any Targets in mind or anything it's
just a general statement that this is a
tough year and we are trying to get
through it without cutting things that
would be very painful to cut and then
would cost more to restore later and so
on and so forth so this is where we are
coming from and I thought that you know
again just understanding a bit more of
the mindset may help you
guys then 40003 the traffic Bureau so
that's where you move the State Police
from Highway fund to general fund and
you did that because not because of the
funding but because to better align them
with their respons with the kinds of
people they work with or something
correct okay thank
you another big enforcement look at
that another big one enforcement but
it's relatively flat down a little which
is
good eyes are crossing this is not
good are the horses Hampton Police or is
that do you have any thing with the
horses I'm just looking at the Hampton
Beach detail um their horses are their
police horses aren't they their mounted
unit is Hampton we have a detail that
supports
Hampton St police for where is
that no it's going
for what I'm looking for I'm looking for
5638 forensic not enforcement
go ahead go ahead thank you on U page
455 count
412 law
enforcement Deb service
those look like leases right it's
not is it Capital Loans what I mean it's
not a big amount but I'm just trying to
understand usually if we see loans that
are longterm we see larger amounts than
that
so I'm trying to figure out if there
just leases that may be accounted as
Debt Service or it's a smaller loans
or it's not any meaningful variation
obviously the payment schedules are the
payment schedules but
but while everybody else is looking for
better
questions rest of you all up to special
expenses page we'll have to get back
with you at the det no stress it
honestly if there is stuff that needs to
be on The Cutting Room floor this could
be one of them if it's easy to find
great if not no don't worry don't jump
ahead I just want I make sure I'm synced
up because I have to jump around with
activities 46 page 46 you must
have you don't have to flip ah head I
just want if you up to that point don't
don't don't
rush my my activities are in different
order than your
activities I would you know for I'm
happy to see you did not need to use a
whole lot in the way of ammunition
with it's
expensive I should know I have enough
thanks for
sharing generically speaking what is
State overhead
charges
4004 it's up on page 460 when you get
there don't don't rush
ahead and everybody's
um this accounting unit is to pay um
administrative services for the S cap
which is a Statewide um cost allocation
plan so just say it again a little
louder um this is up to pay
administrative Services uh for the
Statewide um cost allocation plan the S
thank you
D just a reminder 004 that's the well
inter agency that's not the cost of
collection is that something
else under a funding um uh so um we the
each division has a class 29 which is
inter agency payment and that reimburses
this account so this is just um where
the source of funding is coming from and
then we take this appropriation and pay
administrative Services okay thank you
got three special
expenses more special
expenses oh look at that I'm towards the
end I oh I guess I can go to sleep
now you sleep yeah not
much I'm not one
so is there anything that we've missed
that you all would suggest
we take account of I was going to say
anything we miss they want us to see
well we don't need to qualify
and then should we go through hb2
next is everybody up to that point
or every page every page are are you no
that's fine go go ahead and deal with it
what I said what I meant was
hp2 you okay you with okay going
hp2
okay everybody else okay with hp2 yeah
okay all right should have made her go
to every page to be sure
and do you have the table of contents
you can just take us through
them
yeah oh oh I'm sorry okay is
that that's fine is that on a piece of
paper
or
okay just oral we're going to do this
we're just going to do it
Orly no that's fine just so I understand
what we're doing
uh we do have one additional ask for
house bill to and that is the northern
Bard and Alliance to align with the
executive summ summary from the director
uh the governor's um executive summary
um and we'll provide you um Mickey the
language uh to share but uh we are
asking for uh 600,000 for fiscal year
ending in 20126 for the uh Northern
board and
Alliance so there's already a half a
million dollars each year in this is
that correct so that's Northern Shield
I'll let the department speak to the
difference correct um the northern
Shield is designated for four counties
where this um is
separate separate works but can do a
little more be a little more
explicit well as as we discussed
Northern Shield is the four counties got
it that's the million dollars over the
buum yep the northern border Alliance is
for those Community for those
departments that are are participating
in the northern border Alliance so okay
this appropriation is to get us through
the um the bami so and you had mentioned
that earlier had you not or did I you I
didn't speak to the northern border okay
the question was really focused on so so
Northern Shield is for drugs say again
drug enforcement specifically for drugs
drug enfor and State
Police no and no that's for the counties
counties so that's to build a team so
when we put out granite Shield so that's
funding to locals funding to locals okay
you know Sheriff's departments to do
drug enforcement you just said Granite
Shield are Granite Shield Northern
Shield different things they're the same
okay fine Shield so Shield's a critical
World okay so right this is a new
initiative though um okay so talk about
the new the other one though the the so
the northern border
Alliance GRE is the immigration
enforcement it's it's all criminal
enforcement 25 a
25 air miles South of the Border our
border is 58 miles long so for this
budget we've appropriated 600,000 to
keep it going so is is this police this
is for the New Hampshire State Police
fishing game um the offices that are in
dncr Department of Natural and cultural
resources the Coos County Sheriff's
Department okay the colbrook police
department
the gorm police department North
umberland police department and
Pittsburgh okay so there's nine NBA
northern border Alliance participants
and all will run to your budget this
budget this budget which is in your
domain right yeah okay so it's it's less
than it was in the last bium the last
bium had equipment dollars in there but
we factored in what we have continued
what hasn't lapsed and this is what we
put forward to understanding you know
how many what's the capacity of the
program to keep it going so and the
governor I'm assuming left it
out or it you need it in there because
it's not there
correct I
can't well I'm just trying understand
did the governor was this this was
previously funded through house bill to
got it and now it's being put in our um
operating budget but funded
um it's it's it's reduced um in the bium
because of the funding um that we have
remaining that will um that will still
be able to um support this initiative
moving forward I'm just trying to
understand this hb2 so is did the
governor already have some funding in
the budget yes in hb1 well I I can't
speak to that there are funds remaining
which I'd let Melanie speak to from the
last right the remaining funds were
appropriated from house bill to last by
any minut it's not elapsing so we do
have a current budget for it this is
just adding the extra 600,000 okay so
I'm going to try toass my question again
so did the department present this
request you're presenting to us today to
the governor during the governor's phase
and it just didn't get put in or just
was never even presented to the governor
during the governor's phase correct it
it was presented I think it may have
just been an oversight to add it on okay
but as far as you know what it did it
was put forth at least whether it was
intentional or not yeah absolutely and I
know the governor supports this I'm not
questioning that so I yeah but I think
but but back to being you know fiscally
responsible we looked we look really
closely with melan's Team what are the
existing funds what's the capacity for
these nine agencies how much can we work
how many dollars are we going to need
over the next 24 months to keep these
details going so that's why we came up
with the 600,000 I me you have seen our
ways and means projections
right no no I'm
serious have you seen our ways and means
projections here in the house I know
that there's a shortage
yeah okay there you go kind of an
understatement but yes you're right okay
no I'm I'm aware
okay absolutely represented Roy because
you have a a shortage in Manpower are
you going to be using some drones to
help you up in the North Country to be
able to cover that vast acreage that you
have to sure so I I'm I can't can't I
don't want to speak to anything that's
you know law enforcement sensitive or
what but I mean you know unmanned aerial
systems there's no secret that people
use drones but I think the most
important thing to know is we it took it
it was a lot of work to get this up and
running to get all these Troopers
trained to get the locals trained and be
able to go out and work with um work
with CBP Customs and Border Protection
work and have a partnership um the other
thing is we talk about shortages so a
fair question is how are you going to do
this well they will be working on
overtime and what we do this is run out
of troop F on northernmost Barracks so
the um the troop Commander up there
coordinates it and he works with these
other departments to fill details like
when can we work and I will share this
with you um in speaking to them they
have said it's never been better we
actually are seeing people up here now
where there were none we have none so
they're working more details I mean it's
one thing to have a program but if
nobody's going to work so they are
working they're going to work um so
that's really on on on the border and
you know our our details of this we
those are all public records like what
have we done how many details did they
work how much did they expend how many
vehicles did they stop what type of
arrest the granite shield and now the
northern Shield is focused more on the
investigations the drug traffickers
who's selling drugs you know catching
the drugs before they hit the
communities and and I think it is a very
good idea to get that North Country to
pull together and partner to work
together um really leverage each other
to help them um because it is it's a
long way away from conquer and to do an
investigation the travel time driving up
there but um they've done some great
work and I think that this will will
really build you know it I think they'll
build a build a very strong team up
there and um so
$600,000 on
is that um I wasn't clear 600,000 uh for
the banum or each year and how much is
left in the in the fund we
have so it' be 600 in the first um year
of the fiscal but it would carry in for
so 600 for the baym to answer your
question and then let see if I can get
you the um balance
there is currently a balance of uh um
316 316,000
and what did it start with was it the S
what was the original I'm trying to get
a sense of how much you spent over
that
1.4
35 if I may
um it's okay go ahead go
ahead 24 25 by thank you the exact date
that we again when this started we had
to do the training so it took a while to
get the training so we can provide when
the first when the
operation when the operation began so
just a quick question uh since you have
about 300 I'm assuming that 300 that you
have plus about 600 you're asking for
are the 900 something that you expect to
need to run through the next two years
so basically burn rate is about 450 a
year more or less just trying to
understand where you're coming from
thank
you so we ready to go through hb2
yes we don't need to go back over the
house bill two sections we already
discussed to this point so I would say
the next one would be section 147 on
page 63 and there's section 147 and 148
two different sections that the
department can speak
to uh 63
so the uh first
um the first house bill to change is uh
to add for for uh division of um DMV and
it's just to see to for the Department
of Safety to address uh fictitious
driver's license for undercover
operations so that's why we not needed
to add that extra which which number was
that what section on line uh eight of
page
63 oh 53 I think it's said 63 no it is
page 63 63 line eight
y so in order to have someone go
undercover with a driver's
license you need the special permission
order for that I should think pit would
already have had that permission to do
that that was our guidance from the H's
office be better to codify it in Statue
huh you know
right here he's talking about the fake
driver's licenses this bad is any fake
except now he adds the language talk
specifically or so we get
aover
work so I can't get my fake licenses
anymore
spy so that authorization you said is
for undercover work is that the full
extent of any scenario in which that
authorization would be provided the
authorization for a uh you know
basically fictitious fim or simulated
license and so on and so
forth is there any set of scenarios
other than undercover work that that
authorization May ever be used no and
and again the director of Motor Vehicles
would ensure that there's proper
documentation from the hiring Authority
um whether it's the chief or um to
document who the person is that they
would be working in that capacity and
when the capacity is over that those
documents would be returned just asking
because the law is rather broad as
suggested it would allow you know any
reason you authorize it could be used
and uh I'm not planning to change the
language I just wanted to understand
your internal guard rails in terms of
when that newly available legal
Authority would be used I think it
obviously for a swan state or federal or
County officer I got it's just honestly
obvious and what's in the law can be
different things I learned a long time
ago not to look at the obvious reading
of the law um I hear you okay I I got it
I'm good I I I got the assurances from
you on how it would be used that's
that's what I needed to hear at this
time I'm good I appreciate the question
it's good advice
the second um on Section 148 on the same
page line 12 we add um or authorization
um agents and this is to allow driver
records to be shared with the federal
entity or whoever they've
authorized wonder how bro that can go
that seems like a policy thing right
um I know our state has a high value on
privacy so um is this something we
should try to consider booting to a
policy
committee since I don't there's no appro
appropriation here is that correct so
another one of those things that's not
really a finance
issue could you make a note I believe
chairman wer is already working with
Mike Kane to go through these to
identify policy committees that we could
ask for their input perfect and can we
add in there who's determining who who's
authorized um you know where is this
request coming from and we'll provide
more on that obviously these requests
have commit to the DMV this is something
that they've experienced but you know
fair question with driver privacy we'll
provide more on that what's the detail
he thank you the remaining sections
would be sections 150 151 and 152
starting at the very bottom of page 63
so you see the title there for section
50 and then on to the next
page and we owe you the followup
representative haen on
that may I
may I understand the driving reasons
beside behind the whole group to
retirement thing yes on the HazMat
incident response
coordinator yes
so we have so this kind of plays into
another one that is um next on policy
and planning we have looked at filling
positions in the past and I know that
this position in it of itself is
required by Statute if you look at the
statute of the fire Marshall's office
that position's been vacant for I know
there were there were it was at least
two years and possibly more that it was
vacant and in my regular meetings with
the fire marshal how are we having any
luck do we have any applicants do we we
we know I know we found one person that
stayed for a very short time maybe a
week or two but what it comes down to is
we can't um retain somebody that has
that experience from New Hampshire that
would um also want to collect their
pension or be in group two so that's
what we need
um during full-time Services a hazardous
material incident response quarter the
hazardous material incident response
quarter shall be eligible to be a group
two member so if you're currently in the
fire service today in New Hampshire and
you want to move into this position you
can't unless we fix it or address it so
we're losing a lot of applicants because
of you can't because this isn't to
correct
because you basically lose your
connection to group two well it isn't we
we it's no no but you're already in
group two yes you lose your you lose the
you know the status yeah correct and
nobody I mean I say nobody but generally
not many opt to go from group two to
group one yeah
yeah just asking because obviously group
two tends to be a significantly more
expensive and uh you know but it makes
sense what you're say and I guess I
should be grateful that uh nobody's
requesting for the position to just be
made grouped all together regardless so
I'll take my uh small you know my Silver
Linings here so yeah well and I know and
if if you really look at it I mean it's
such an important position the hazardous
material materials response coordinated
for the entire
State and and I'm I don't I'm not
familiar at all with the job
requirements for this but I would assume
that they tend to be quite closely
aligned to um experience that one can
only acquire in New Hampshire through a
group two position sure and there's a
lot of great firefighters is Hazmat
teams spread across the state right now
but this position is more in the fire
moners office to you know our you know
offer support and really coordination
and and it is a it is an important
position but is it a very specific
firefighter type skills or is it an
administrative position that's what I'm
trying to understand no it's skills and
dealing with these hazardous materials
recognizing them understanding it you
know what's the incident command whether
it's a tanker that spills over or
certain chemicals or um so it's it's
it's really huh thank you I got it and
and I'll tell you what I I we will
provide what's you know in the job
description for that I think it's I
think it's a good question so we'll
provide some follow up on
that edit as an editorial comment Mr
chair it seems like there's several
positions at the department of safety
and I'm willing to guess across our
agencies that um our ability to fill
positions at um some of the mid-level or
higher ranks of the
Departments um the compensation plan is
not currently matching um you know the
kind of incentives that we need people
to move up the system it sounds like
this is a larger problem than just one
or two positions that we're hearing
about today and
um gosh that's that's alarming if we're
having if we're having this in more than
one discussion um so I wonder you know
maybe these are little fixes that we can
help you know independently for some
current needs that the agencies are
bringing to us but this sounds like a
big project in the
future good we'll put you in charge no
thank you
and then cut
everything is that are we done with that
one or other there all that we could ask
for now and we'll get more back so the
next one well I'll let you speak to
before I ask a
question uh for Section 151 um we are
looking to remove so uh uh when we made
this submission we inadvertently um
requested as a add and not a removal so
lines 19 through 23 should be
um repealed or removed oh the last two
sentence on a so I'm on page 50 uh
64 so starting from the use of properly
licensed correct all the way to the end
it's ince it is so um both sentences
should be removed it was inadvertently
submitted as an addition when it should
have been um
removed okay so there's one sentence
instead of two or in both line both
lines should be removed we're removing
you want both deleted both
lines basically instead of seeing it as
a bold Edition it was meant to be a
strike through the original language and
no bold paragraph you know it happens
don't worry about it they I'm perfect
I'll throw stones at
other yeah s why would you remove the
provision of using on a proper witer van
or vehicle um this is being requested uh
because the assignment of the transport
are val um validated through um
Department of Health and Human human
services so it's already being um
address through that
agency so um it doesn't need to be
included so we're not taking anything
away or putting someone in the back of
the station wagon corre Health and Human
Services is
doing so is it just removing basically
redundant
language because honestly redundant
language is a pain in the tou because
you try to edit it in one place you
don't realize it's in the second place
and now you created a conflict so
anytime we can identify redundant
language where it's in five places it
should only be in one so we you know
it's easier to read and understand so I
really appreciate these types of efforts
to prune a little back thank
you Bas language somewhere else it
does okay else out with that
one uh the following one uh following
section uh 152 is similar to uh section
150 where we're looking to have this
position um have group two
available discussion
so I'm not going to repeat my
question
Mr any other questions on that one
no okay and then the last section for
the Department of Safety is on page 70
or uh page 73 and that's just the
language which we already talked about
for the transfer from oplc to Department
of Safety I'm
familiar y mechanical licensing very
bottom of 73 last line
so is it two sections that relate to the
same or three sections two
sections is 190 related to 190 to
189 yes it is yes that's the RSA for
oplc they're just updating it from oplc
to reflect um State Fire Marshall yep
okay just how curi did you go before
division
one no we didn't no
okay should we at
least I mean you can speak with
representative Maguire um okay typically
we do have some sections that do cross
uh divisions and we kind of just try to
send them to one because it's a little
yeah makes sense I gets a little
complicated to do code division work so
tot can I assuming assuming that
division one approves op plc's budget as
it is I would say they are blessing this
indirectly yeah all
right so anything
else you need to ask a question
I'm sorry go ahead can I add just a
little bit of context one of these I
know we're going to take a little
different route and um perhaps ask other
folks but to the one on page 63 line 12
where um the request is to um add a
language or their authorized agent I
want to just go back um as a reminder
about the fire fund so and I'm just
going to repeat this
um for context um so if you recall the
fire fund is funded um through fees
collected for providing copies of Motor
Vehicle records and certificates as
authorized under RSA 260 subsection 14
these records are typically requested by
insurance companies and other authorized
entities so without this language What's
Happening Here is that um so we ENT
enter into with the DMV enters into umus
with these companies and they want to do
business with us but they use an
authorized agent to do this work and so
we are not able to work with them and so
that's why we wanted to add this
language so that we can um do business
in an ongoing way with them so can you
remember me what that account is that
you were referring to so I can just go
make a mark 6631 6631 that sounds
familiar go ahead could we clarify the
language then if that's what that's for
instead of or their authorized agents
because that sounds like you know it
could be a federal contractor it sounds
like that door could swing wide open so
maybe we could just limit it to the need
that we're talking
about and if I may very briefly
um I very much care about the right to
privacy and there are certain legal
doctrines that irk me to no end these
days third party Doctrine don't get me
started cuz we don't have an hour but in
this case it would seem to me that since
we are talking about the federal entity
or their authorized agent not allowing
to release to an authorized agent
basically just means the federal entity
can request the same data and then pass
it along to their you know once we
release it to a federal entity they are
bound by their rules so as long as we're
releasing it to them to me doesn't seem
to create a much bigger problem because
we release them to an authorized entity
by a federal agency but this being said
I would probably still be more
comfortable if the policy committee
would have an opportunity to look at it
or because it does seem to be a policy
question and you know our hands are full
with the money God knows uh you know I
don't want to miss an important detail
because we are overwhelmed by the rest
of our job so and we'll do that could
you just put into writing what you said
and send it to Mickey so we abely
absolutely I can't keep in my head thank
you no it's that
I anything else from our committee
anything else from you
all I want to thank you for your time
and um patience thank you for showing up
I want to thank my
team they are M they're awesome and so
are you now this has been very helpful
thank you very much and an excellent
presentation and very well prepared
really appreciate all the work that went
into this very pleasant two plus hours
together thank you thank
you sad sad
puppy starting at
9 so first all are we done we anything
else we wanted to discuss okay so at uh
311 I'll close the division 2 finance
committee
hearing you asking about Friday yeah
just
Friday we play true with Transportation
people bring the Hat go ahead you know
what it is public transportation you're
explain e